this is jocko podcast number 239
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
and also joining us tonight is dave
burke good evening dave
good evening so last podcast we went
through
the woo z which you did some
you did some research and we did not
come up with the meaning of the word
z other than room okay
so woozy by wuchi from ancient china a
lot of
solid leadership lessons in there and
i was thinking about these leadership
principles
and how leadership principles are not
supposed to change
right that's kind of you know i say oh
you know leadership principles stay the
same
and when you read through the woozy you
start to get some supporting evidence to
that
because he's talking about the fact that
you need to be benevolent and you need
to treat people well
and treat them with respect and take
care of your people
which is all things that you know i talk
about we all talk about
but then in the woozy it also says
to execute anyone that disobeys your
orders
so so that leads you think well
maybe some principles have changed and
you know i used to actually
have a rationalization for this or an
excuse for this
and what i would say is there's there's
a difference in leadership
when you're leading conscripts
instead of volunteers and so as
leadership moved away from on military
leadership and that
by the way when you go back in time it's
not just military leadership because
what are the people the people are serfs
and peasants and
they're being led by these kings
with divine power so
but as time went by it's like okay so
that's why the leadership principle
might not
really fit maybe that's why it changes
but then i started thinking about that
what if you go ahead and actually let
those things play out
right and actually that question has
been answered
right that's what history is and what
happens is if you're
executing people if you're not treating
people the right way
as leaders what happens eventually what
do you get you get a revolution
you get people to
come after you and take you out of power
and look
just like we talk about you can get
people on board for a little while
right if i have you know 5 000 soldiers
and they see me execute two people that
didn't follow my orders they're gonna
follow my orders
for a little while right maybe for a
long time maybe since that extreme
measure
maybe they'll follow my orders for a
year they'll just live in fear but when
that opportunity arrives
for them to step up
and take that power away from me they're
going to do it it's what we see play out
and then the other side so so now we go
to the
side of okay so i'm gonna take care of
my people that's what i'm gonna do
but just like we say that doesn't mean
we coddle our people
because if we coddle our people then
they're they're soft
and they destroy themselves they they
fall apart
so and we see that play out in the world
when when a society gets too soft
they can no longer survive so
even in ancient times with conscripts
and
and peasants and serfs and slaves if you
let
things play out the leadership
principles still actually apply
and and then i started thinking about
tactics which this is another thing that
i used to
sort of i used to i used to sort of say
the same thing
about tactics which is hey you know
the principles on the battlefield they
don't change
until you go before the machine gun
right or the at least the gun
right because that's that's where you
start to talk about covered move and
that's where it really plays into
plays into how you're going to fight
but then if you adjust your perspective
a little bit
if we're fighting with spears and we're
in a phalanx
guess what i've got my shield i'm
holding my shield up
it protects the left part of my body and
it protects the right
part of the person to my left and i'm
being protected covered by
the person on my right and what we're
going to do is cover for each other as
we advance with the phalanx
so we still have to look out for each
other teamwork still
absolutely applies
and then i was thinking about the fact
that
you know here's a here's a military
principle
that i'm just trying to think of things
that don't apply right well
in modern combat we follow a rule of
dispersion meaning we want to be spread
apart we don't want to be too close
together
so that's obviously completely contrary
to the idea of being in a phalanx where
we're going to get as close as we can
we're going to keep tight we're going to
move forward
but if you change your perspective just
a little bit
you and this is this is one of those
doctrinal terms that i was able to
uncover because of what i used to tell
guys
is hey if you're alone on the
battlefield you're gonna die if you get
too far away from your element
the other element you can't support each
other that's what cover move is so if
you're too far away
you're you can't support each other and
you will get killed because if we're
alone we die
and that that doctrinal term that when i
found it i used to get these beautiful
satisfactory
satisfactory moments in my life where i
would have an idea and then i would see
that it already existed
and and that doctrinal term that i would
then walk around as if i
as if i knew it you know as if as if it
was just you know
but it's called supporting distance so
you dave shouldn't take your squad
beyond where my reign the wep the range
of my weapons
and then when you start to talk about
that that means you know communications
as well if i don't can't get
you know communications with you then i
can't support you if my weapons can't
reach out and touch
and give you support then we're not in
supporting distance and that's too far
away what does that mean
you just change your perspective a
little bit
and dispersion which is positive but if
you get too far apart
it's negative
so these
lessons are the same over time and yet
we still have to teach them because we
still make mistakes
and when we learn things from a
different angle and even reading
a document yesterday that's thousands or
the last podcast of documents thousands
of years old
you'd think to yourself that after
thousands of years
thousands of years we would be talking
about these
leadership principles in the most
commonly known way that everybody just
like you know i i couldn't have written
extreme ownership because people would
have been just
you know saying hey no kidding dude what
are you talking about this is this is
this is part of the fabric of life but
these things aren't
they're they're not they're not the
fabric of life
they're they they just seem to need to
be rediscovered over and over again
which is which is horrible but one thing
i think
allows us to learn them in a more
complete way
is seeing them from different angles
from other experiences
and today we're going to take a look at
combat lessons
which you know and that's the name of
the document you're
you're setting up in a good spot the
subtitle it's published in 1944 the
subtitle
is rank and file in combat
what they're doing how they are doing it
so you know when i see that i'm thinking
okay
we are going to learn something so with
that
we will bust into this book combat
lessons
number one i've got number two i'm sure
it'll make
appearance in the future the
introduction to this thing
this is one of those things where you
get done reading the introduction and
maybe you don't even have to read
anything else because you're just almost
there
introduction the purpose of combat
lessons
is to give our officers and enlisted men
the benefit of the battle experiences of
others which comes right out of uh
learning united states marine corps to
be of maximum benefit
these lessons must be disseminated
without delay
they do not necessarily represent the
carefully considered views of the war
department
they do however reflect the actual
experiences of combat and therefore
merit careful merit careful reading
for this reason also no single issue
can cover many of the phases of combat
lessons will be drawn from the reports
as they are received
from the theaters of operation and
quickly disseminated so that others may
apply them
the suggestions which are made or
implied are not intended to change the
tactical doctrine
by which our army has been trained but
rather to elaborate
thereon much of the subject matter
has been covered in training literature
but the comments show
that shortcomings continue to manifest
themselves on the battlefield
and then it says this the paramount
combat lesson learned from every
operation is the vital
importance of leadership
our equipment our supply and above all
are men are splendid
aggressive and determined leadership is
the priceless factor
which inspires a command and upon which
all
success in battle depends
it it is responsible for success
or failure
i don't know if i have that thing
trademarked of leadership is the most
important thing on the battlefield
mm-hmm i don't i don't know if i but i
don't know if i could even get a
trademark
right same exact thing
same exact thing this is a signed by
general marshall
who's the chief of staff in the army
during world war ii
he was in world war one first division
he was a infantry platoon commander in
the
philippine-american war and he's signing
this thing
so let's jump into it
and and you're gonna see that this is
one of the most straightforward
documents
that built well it's as straightforward
as you can get because all it is
basically is quotes from people on the
front lines
that's all it is just quotes there's no
there's
there's some little added commentary
occasionally
section one infantry
again and again reports from the
battlefields confirm the importance of
leadership
in every grade whether it be corporal or
colonel
other combat lessons are important
the exercise of leadership in battle is
vital leadership has often been defined
in theory
here are some instances of its
application or its absence on the
battlefield
these are but a few examples there are
many others
junior officer in battle captain t
captain william t
gordon infantry sicily since november
8th
i have had 17 officers in my company
and i am the only one who started out
with it who is left to fight
in tunisia the from troops pinned down
in the dark i have heard enlisted men
call out such things as where is an
officer to lead us
we don't want to lie here we want to
attack
where is an officer in each case an
officer or officers have risen to the
occasion
but this nevertheless shows beyond
anything else
the demand for battle leadership
you know what's interesting dave we had
a we just kind of went
off yesterday during ef online
talking about the leadership vacuum
right
and knowing when to step up and this is
these situations right here you know my
immediate
my immediate thought is if i don't have
enlisted if i have enlisted people that
are calling out you know hey
where's an officer we want to attack i'm
i'm not happy with my training i'm not
happy with my troops i'm not happy with
the job that i did
i'm not happy with my performance in
preparing them for combat
because if they need if there's a
leadership vacuum and no one's stepping
up they need to step up
totally
we had a conversation again that was on
ef online yesterday
where you be just because you're in
charge doesn't mean you need to talk
in fact if you don't
need to talk then you shouldn't talk
if i walk into a room if we're having a
meeting at echelon front
and jamie our operations
director is you know if she's if she's
putting out the word about what's going
to happen and i go in there and i see
that she's got the timeline laid out and
she's telling
us where we need to be at what time and
we're getting ready for the muster and
she's got everything laid out
what do i need to say
i mean i'm officially in charge what do
i need to say
maybe maybe looks good thank you
like maybe so
you don't need to step up and you know i
went into great detail on this and
leadership strategy and tactics talking
about this
this leadership vacuum and how it
appears sometimes and
the real nitty-gritty techniques that
you
pay attention to one of the things that
you pay attention to is
if there's a leadership vacuum and no
one else knows it they're not
ready for they might not be ready to
make it
to to follow when no one knows there's
when they don't sense it when they're
just kind of sitting there oh we're
doing okay
and you say hey we need to move your
immediate response might be why
wait what are you talking about they
haven't sensed the leadership vacuum
they don't know that there's a problem
so sometimes you hesitate just a little
bit longer
let everyone feel that
feel that lack of leadership and then
when you step in there with a command
boom they're waiting for it they're
waiting for it
and that is an important thing and
that's an important
it's an important dichotomy i'm sorry i
have to say it's important dichotomy is
that
yes there will be many many times when
you as a leader don't have to say
anything
and there will be many many times where
your team
is absolutely waiting and
begging to be told hey this is what we
need to do
now
back to the book a company officer must
build a legend about himself
he must take calculated risks he must on
the other hand
do what he expects his men to do he must
always dig in
always take cover his men must know that
when he ducks
they must duck on the other hand they
must not believe
that when the officer ducks they must
run away
the officer must come through every
barrage
and bombing with a sheepish grin and
awry
remark masterly
understatement of hardship and danger
endured
plus a grin always pays dividends
yeah um we got ambushed my my first
deployment to iraq
and i was in vehicle two and
the tail end because we were driving
fast at night and everything and
they got and i saw i mean i saw us
getting ambushed but we were going fast
it was on up
it was on a highway south of baghdad and
you know i'm looking and at this point
we were we were
we would face not forward we would face
out the sides and so you know i see rpgs
going over and exploding and
tracer fire um to and from
and but then you know what we just you
know the lead drivers like push through
push through which is just kind of what
we're going to do
keep going and then
the shooting stops and we're still
driving and then
my my my chief who is in the rear
vehicle which is
purposely set up that way because that
way if you have to reverse you've got
you know your lea
your your most senior leader enlisted
leaders in the back he's gonna take
and also if something goes wrong he's
gonna assess so he's back there
and you know he says
he he's they got they got you know those
rpgs were close a lot closer to him than
they were to me
he comes up he's like hey sir which you
know
first of all he rarely would call me sir
you know but he's like hey sir
you know he got ambushed back here and i
could hear his voice he's a little
freaked out
and uh i waited a solid you know like
10 seconds and then i came up and said
roger and that was it you know they once
we got down to where we were going
they're all like oh roger you know
so yeah i like this thing of you know
hey just a little grin a rye remark
will be good it's kind of like when your
kid falls down yes
exactly like when your kid falls down
and then he looks at you kind of like
what are we doing here we crying
or we whatever and then yeah you know
no big deal kind of a thing we're
laughing
yeah we're laughing you know i used to
say like oh that was awesome
nice yeah yo check out this
check out your leg it's gonna bleed
yeah my kid came home yesterday just
blood everywhere he hit the reef
you were so proud no i was just you know
he's just covered in blood
and like yeah the reef will get you
yeah for sure the barnacles what it is
out here in california
the reefs are just rock it's not coral
yeah like you always hear about the
coral reefs with the razors
oh yeah this is just rocks but they have
barnacles on them if you go touch a
barnacle
they're sharp and if you fall and you
scrape against them you're getting cut
open you're going to be bleeding
everywhere
but do not come into the house with the
blood is the main level
of the story get the hose get take care
of business
next section
this is an interesting one and this
really shows you
this is one of those things where you
think you know the world is different
this was a different time this
section says hate your enemy
our men do not ordinarily hate they must
hate they are better soldiers when they
hate
they must not fraternize with prisoners
must not give them
cigarettes and food the moment they are
taken hate can be taught
men by meticulous example
the rangers are so taught
that's a different world that is not in
any
modern army publications
and then you think about
you know world war ii you think about
what those guys were going into you
think about what you had to get
but the mindset you had to bring out in
people when they were
in a landing craft and they were gonna
go land on tarawa or
iwo jima or normandy
you gotta you gotta dig deep
it's an interesting it's an interesting
comment
we are we are at total war
just so everyone doesn't freak out this
isn't taught anymore
and i will say this it's not taught
anymore right now
but we better remember this because if
the world
we could get to a place where this is
needed again
i'm sorry to report i hope we don't i
hope we can always
be going into wars saying yup it's a
small element of people and
they've got some bad feelings and
they've got some reasons for their
their anger towards us but we need to go
and
show them that we're a benevolent group
and we can help them move
yeah those are all that's great
hopefully we fight wars like that
hopefully we don't have to fight anymore
wars where the doctrine
is being adjusted to get us to hate our
enemy
next one leaders in front
staff sergeant richard e deland
infantry sicily we want our captains
out front we don't much care about the
position of our battalion commander
that's it that's all that's the whole
note
keep them moving
operation report seventh army sicily
during an attack officers and
non-commissioned officers must never
allow men to lie
prone and and passive under enemy fire
they must be required to move forward if
this is at all possible
if movement is absolutely impossible
have the troops
at least open fire
the act of firing induces
self-confidence in attacking troops
the familiar expression dig or die has
been greatly
overworked attacking troops must not be
allowed to dig in
until they have secured their final
objective
if they dig in when momentarily stopped
by enemy fire
it will take dynamite to blast them from
their holes and resume the advance
this is another thing and we're going to
get into some of this
there's another element again where you
get to total war
and and that's what that's what that's
what that's what these things are
leaning towards we're in a totally
different situation you know this is
this is an
existential war where if we don't win
america is not going to exist freedom
will not exist in the world
nco leadership staff sergeant robert j
kemp
platoon sergeant infantry sicily nco
leadership is important
leaders ncos and officers should be
taken to an op
for terrain instruction and study before
an attack
this has been possible in my outfit
about one-fourth of the time
we have what is called an orders group
which consists of that group of officers
and ncos
that must be assembled for instruction
before any tactical move
simple clear concise orders get people
together get face to face with them
look at the terrain show them what
they're seeing
show them where they're going to move to
and this seems real obvious and yet this
guy is saying hey you better do it
keep your mission in mind colonel e.b
thayer field artillery observer with
fifth army italy
difficulty was experienced in making
patrol leaders realize the importance of
bringing back information by a specified
hour in time to be of value
patrols often returned after
encountering resistance without
accomplishing their mission
sending them back to accomplish their
mission despite their fatigue
seemed to be the most effective solution
to the training problem involved
although the information required often
arrived too late
and then this other guy says this is
lieutenant colonel
t f bogart infantry
and if actually dave i know you haven't
heard this yet
i went on kind of a massive tangent the
other day on the last podcast about
seeing some of the seal machine gunners
and and just how in tuned they were
with their weapons and the great lengths
that they would go
to develop their own personal individual
standard operating procedures
so that they're working that thing like
a painter works a brush
and just i said if if i could take
videos and there's two guys in
particular that that i was i've actually
went through seal training with both of
them and then i ended up in platoons
with them at seal team one
back in the day and if i had videos
of them assaulting through targets
with their m60 machine guns and the
the the incredible smoothness with which
they would
handle the weapon and and open up the
feed tray and slap
out extra links and pull out their new
belt and slap feet
just it would look beautiful and i was
like if if we could have
if you could post those videos no one
would want to go to war with america if
they know people like that are out there
and it's not and obviously it's not just
sealed machines it's like
every it's like there is a pocket of
every
every sector of the military where there
are people that is
what they are doing that's who they are
yeah there's there's a version of that
in everything for the people that
they kind of fall in love with what
they're doing you know when they just
fall in love whatever their job is i was
just kind of remarking as you go through
these
they're said in a way that i can't think
of anything else to say other than
yeah yeah do that that's really good and
so that the way he said it
is is right and i'm kind of racking my
brain like how can i create some context
around this like no that's that's it
that's pretty good um so i think i'm
just going to sit here for the next hour
listen to you
repeat what these guys have said but i
mean the thing that's crazy about it is
they seem so obvious and it's like you
said earlier is
in some ways it's a little bit
disheartening at how often they need to
be repeated
because the way they're saying it isn't
really that complex like man that's
that's as clear as anybody could say it
do you think you take a statement and
this this goes back to what we were
talking about
as far as hey i'm a leader if i walk
into a room and i sit through the brief
and nothing needs to be said
i'm not going to say anything if someone
takes a
something like a fundamental principle
of combat
cover and move right and they say okay
but i'm going to expand on that a little
bit
and then they expand on it and then
someone else expands on that expansion
then someone else expands on that
expansion
and the next thing you know you don't
even you can't you can't see cover and
move anymore
become something else
sure the the the the complexity of those
things that's i think why these things
are so powerful
i was even writing down little notes to
myself of what was my version
of what you were just saying i wrote
down like
we had the phrase mutual support that's
what we called it in airplanes we had to
apply mutual support to each other let's
cover and move kind of just cover a move
that's all it is and
technology has sort of redefined
where we would need to be to apply that
mutual support
but the principle hasn't changed but if
you're not careful and you get too
wrapped up around this piece of
technology allows me to get to this
range
over time you lose the idea that all
that really matters is that you and i
work
closely enough together that i can cover
you and you can cover me
and those roles will go back and forth
in some sort of unknown
it's not predetermined it's just gonna
happen and the better we are the more
naturally
it happens but all it is is mutual
support and i remember sitting in briefs
i'm like hang on are you just saying you
want me to stay a certain distance away
from you so i can help you with the
and when we interact with other aircraft
hey just say that
and if i it's training too because if i
get it wrong we can just come back and
debrief it it's okay
but you have spent like nine minutes
talking about the nuances of that when
there's no way to predict
and i've lost sight of what you're
really trying to tell me which is don't
get too far away man
check the i that just made me think
i was up with an air wing in fallon
and i remember i don't even this this is
definitely one of my
early sort of graspings of the idea of
covered move
was we would put a a a squad
on the ground and when we would get
extracted
when we put on the ground or we get
i remember briefing the helicopter
pilots and i don't know if i learned it
from them or
i don't know but i remember saying hey
and i actually have i have a i have a
book that i wrote
i have a book that i wrote when i was at
seal team when i was a communicator
it's called communications and a lot of
it
i wrote it with a buddy of mine who is
another communicator
and he wrote a lot of this technical
stuff about how to operate each
individual radio
and i just wrote my section
i mean i helped him a little bit with
that very little
because he was smarter than me and so he
wrote you know how to do the little
things and
but i wrote all the stuff about hey when
you're calling in a helicopter
here's what you need to do and and i'm
going to find this because i have this
book i have it
and and one of the things i said was
leave one helicopter
at altitude to provide cover fire for
the helicopter that's on the ground
and here i was a new guy kind of
thinking that i had a little something
you know i had a little something for
these guys
and that's one of the initial kind of
thoughts around or me starting to
realize that cover and move wasn't just
that that really was the fundamental of
everything that we were doing
and and the other thing that i scratched
down
when i talk about people you're talking
about people being really good at their
jobs
i was doing some kind of an exercise up
at camp pendleton and somehow
we got linked into a mortar a marine
corps mortar element
and bro these guys were doing i-ads
immediate action drills with their
mortars and
you know i just remember watching them
and i don't know what i don't know how
you put words
but you know they were you know they're
freaking 18 years old
and they hear you know contact right and
then boom
a guy's slapping down the base plate the
guys put his
sights on for their bomb and they're
getting rounds out like
in so fast i don't know how fast it was
but so
fast accurate rounds and then
immediately correcting
bracketing and they're good and they're
on target and you just think
you know what we're good america's good
all right lieutenant colonel tf bogart
greater emphasis must be placed on
inculcating in junior officers and ncos
the will to accomplish assigned missions
despite
opposition a few accounts of patrol
actions illustrate this point
and he goes through these a
reconnaissance patrol consisting of a
platoon was sent out about 1900 one
evening to determine the strength of any
if any of germans in two small towns the
first about two miles away
and the second about three miles farther
on the patrol reached the outskirts of
the first town and met an italian who
told them there were no germans in the
town and then started to lead the patrol
into town a few hundred yards further
farther a german machine gun opened up
the italian disappeared three of the
patrol were killed and the others
dispersed they drifted back to our
battalion during the night
and it was not until nearly daylight
that the
practically valueless report of action
was received
not the slightest conception of the
strength of the first town was obtained
and no information of the second town it
was necessary
to send out another patrol with the same
mission
so that's that's number one
and again i think this is this is this
just shows you that this is a different
time
and they're like hey you took some
casualties you got three guys killed you
it doesn't matter you got it you still
gotta go figure out what the strength
was in there
obviously you got some germans in there
and by the way there's another town two
miles away you need to go get on that
too
that is not a consistent attitude with
uh current
operations right where you go oh yeah we
took three casualties but we're
continuing down here on this
reconnaissance mission by the way
freaking legit two a patrol sent out
with the mission of determining the
condition of a road especially bridges
over a three-mile stretch
to the front when this patrol had
covered about a mile it ran into a
motorized german patrol two of the
americans were killed and the platoon
leader claimed
six germans the patrol leader forgot his
mission returned to the battalion cp
with the remainder of his patrol
and had to be sent out again with a
great loss in time getting the
information desired
this dude's out there gets into contact
with a motorized german patrol has two
guys
killed killed six germans comes back to
base he's probably totally
amped and feeling like he did a great
job and they say
hey did you complete your mission no oh
roger that
go back out these are hard men
yeah last one on several occasions
patrols were sent out on reconnaissance
missions with extra instruction to get
certain information by a specific time
the hour would pass and sometimes
several others
without a word from the patrol sometimes
it was due to difficulties encountered
sometimes to mistakes and computation of
time and space factors
but in all cases there was no good
reason why some information
didn't get back by the specified time
and here's i said there were some
occasional comments
amplifying information so here's the
comment comment the failure of patrols
in these instances
stems from a lack of appreciation on the
part of ncos and junior officers
of their missions in patrol actions
as in the operations of larger units the
mission must be kept
uppermost in the minds of all ranks and
no action should be undertaken which
does not contribute directly
to the accomplishments accomplishment of
that mission
conversely no incidental or inadvertent
contact with the enemy should deter or
divert
patrols from the complete accomplishment
of their missions
to include compliance with all
instructions given where humanly
possible
these guys are freaking just legit
that's because this is total war yeah
that's because this is
an existential war
there's there's so much insulation that
we sometimes try to create and i
remember feeling it
on my deployment to ramadi which was
very different than my deployments in an
aircraft
and i even remember feeling the sense of
wanting to insulate my own
family from what i was doing the feeling
of just wanting to keep them insulated
from the reality
when actually all that did to be honest
with for my wife is made it
made it kind of worse because she had to
create something in her mind and she had
to
try to piece it together which she
simply couldn't do but that need to
insulate if that ends up on the inside
with your own folks
and it becomes most obvious when you
start losing people
and and the question of hey how much
time are we going to take
how much downtime we're going to take
and i'm listening to this
and it's like that's not even a there's
not we're not even that conversation
isn't even happening
we're not we're not talking about hey
what are we gonna do to acknowledge what
has happened here
which of course you want to do but
this is not an option and the leadership
isn't even contemplating that
it's funny the way he said that my mind
immediately went like i want to write
that differently instead of the staff
ncos and the junior officers not
understanding it it's
the leadership has failed to explain to
them the context
that they should understand and we
actually aren't doing
our jobs i might have gotten ahead of
myself it looks like you're laughing at
something but
i'm laughing even when he said that i
was like no that's not what happened
yeah i'm laughing because you can see my
note right there says ownership
question mark exact same thing is you
know when you when you blame
your ncos and your junior officers
because they don't appreciate
their mission and they don't understand
it well guess what whose fault is that
all day long totally it's my fault as a
leader for letting those junior officers
go out there
and i'm not sitting over here trying to
pick apart the things they're saying i'm
just picturing
every time every time i placed a demand
on
guys on my team that they understood it
wasn't even hard for them to step up i
mean it was a challenging situation but
if they understand why we were just
stepping up and making things happen
when it was hard
no factor my 18 year old marines were
gone no factor
but if i failed to give them that and
then something difficult happened that
created some friction and some
some doubt that was a much harder
problem to get past
if they didn't understand why they
needed to get past it and that was
always
always on me always or it was on the 18
year old kid
on his very first deployment that one of
his closest friends had just gotten
killed it's either on him
or it's on me it's not even hard but if
you gave him that context
what they could overcome and endure
i don't mean to say that it wasn't hard
maybe that's the wrong way to describe
it but boy they did it
every single time without hesitation
yeah and that's that's the whole us
military even though
you know as i read this i'm like man
these guys were hard but that's what we
do in the military you know
you take casualties
and then you you go you go do your job
that's what you do
next one team up captain william t
gordon infantry sicily
i have found that men in position must
fight in pairs and order that 50
stay awake is thus easily enforced it
bolsters
morale and nerves rally point in every
company attack order
a reserve force must be prescribed i
always do
even though sometimes this force
consists only of myself and my first
sergeant
often a soldier who a moment before is
run away is converted to a fighter
by leadership a reserve force gives him
a rallying point
that's brilliant just having a fallback
point even if it's two people
hey if you gotta run away run to here
and then who's there
the platoon commander and the first
sergeant like all right buddy here take
some ammo
get ready cause we're gonna rock and
roll
fear is normal
colonel george taylor infantry sicily
fear of being afraid is the greatest
obstacle for the new man
in battle to overcome there is no reason
for shame and being afraid
men who have had excellent battle
records freely admit
they are scared stiff in battle the
important thing
is that every soldier must be taught all
he needs to know
so well that battlefield thinking is
reduced to a minimum
automatic disciplined reactions to
battlefield problems
must be the rule
in battle the worst element is mental
and nervous exhaustion
there is no real rest under fire the
ability to withstand fire
is more important than all the knowledge
in the world
what are you writing down nervous
exhaustion yeah
the idea that you will exhaust yourself
and render yourself
incapable just by creating the fear in
your mind
by when you don't react to what's going
on you just you and you
i've seen it where people get
overwhelmed by the moment and they end
up doing nothing
and they literally exhaust themselves in
in their own minds
by being afraid of what's out there
rather than just
facing what's out there which is
extremely hard to do
but just the way he wrote that that
nervous example is such an awesome way
to describe
what sometimes people do when they're
just freaking out of what's happening
they exhaust themselves into doing
nothing
the i i got mortared a couple times and
actually my platoon of my first
deployment we went to this
out station it was a special forces
outstation it was in a rough
neighborhood in in baghdad and
we got mortared a decent amount that
night and
um like the next day
let me rephrase that we probably got hit
with
a an rpg or two
maybe a rifle fired grenade
and then
i don't know some number of mortars
more than more than three or four
likes decent right which
by the way when you compare it to this
is just
nothing it's just nothing and the reason
i bring it up because
even that one night you know one night
of receiving
some pretty consistent mortar fire
was enough that you could see the next
day guys were
on edge guys were legitimately on edge
after one night of light mortar attacks
and that's just crazy
and you could see that
over time and it's what we see in world
war one you know those awful videos of
world war one of guys that had shell
shock legit shell shock
and when we when we covered shot at dawn
on here
you know you break down people break
down and it doesn't matter what you say
what you do you're telling them you're
gonna shoot them if they
if they desert and they do it anyways
so the ability to withstand fire is more
important than all the knowledge in the
world
i'll tell you something else
i think the ability to withstand fire is
related to
an acceptance of death
i mean if you are
if you are scared of dying this is going
to drive you insane
yeah i think that's the nervous
exhaustion right there you're gonna go
insane if that's what you think
think about look man when i
got when i got to ramadi
i was afraid of dying for a very brief
period of time
but i was i got there and i i remember
i wrote about and i remember realizing
as i probably was there for you know
a little bit i had in some ways the
benefit of knowing people that have been
there knowing knowing knowing what i was
going to get myself into but when i got
there i'm like oh man
i'm here now and i remember thinking for
a little while like
oh this maybe maybe this is a bad idea
maybe this was a mistake
and there was a little bit of fear of
dying and
the time that i spent thinking about
that was it's par
it was it was exhausting and then
i you know i said you know what that yes
that might happen i
i literally considered to myself yep
that might happen and i got past it and
that was the end of it i never
lost the idea that it could happen i
fully understood that but i sort of just
stopped thinking about it
i didn't stop thinking about it because
i didn't think it would happen i just
stopped thinking about it because it was
a kind of a useless thing to think about
anymore
but if you get trapped in that and i
remember a small period of time of that
feeling of like
the paranoia that starts to build up of
what you can end up creating is that
you're going to die there's no way to
get out of it and that becomes
the obsession that you think about if
you're going to go to combat you have to
accept that that might happen
and then you have to get past that and
then go do whatever it is you're going
to go do
knowing that's a case without letting it
control you at all
but again what i was going to face in my
brush with war compared to any of this
other stuff
is kind of crazy yeah there's another
end of the spectrum too
and i think i kind of went back and
forth between
two mindsets of one is
you know what i i can die that'll that
could happen tonight
and you know what i'm not going to die
that's not going to happen
you know what whatever watch this i'll
stand out here in the street doesn't
matter they can't kill me
i mean in my first deployment to iraq
uh what did i write on my humvee
door once we got the um
we welded steel steel on there i think
i think i wrote um i cannot be killed on
it
and my guys made me take it off they
were so freaked out they're like
oh don't do that man that's a total jinx
don't do it don't do it so and you know
even talking to dean ladd
dean lad you know going into tarawa
it's like oh did you think you were
going to get killed and he's like no of
course not what are you
you think i'm weak yeah and that might
be the greatest story of all time when
his buddy went he pretended like he was
dying
his buddy pretended like he was dying
and had his his friend the
the chaplain come over and was reading
him his last rights and
then he starts laughing
all right next section is about sicily
italy
and at two night attacks
and they get into attu which is that the
battle up on the aleutian island of the
the the island of a two
2 900 japanese soldiers
2870 of them killed
28 captured
surprise saves lives major john r
patterson
infantry sicily the mission of our
battalion after landing it
south south of gala in sicily was to
capture
the airport at biscari the battalion
used the silent knight attack
three rifle companies were in line with
heavy machine
with heavy weapons company in reserve to
reach its line of departure the
battalion crossed two
ridges using control two control lines
then climbed the cliff at the airport to
the line of departure all this was done
silently under the cover of darkness
the attack was started with a hand
grenade we didn't fire until the
germans counter-attacked when we
went with we went in with bayonets and
hand grenades and caught some of the
germans
undressing and dressing the tanks fired
their guns but
wouldn't close on us the enemy knew
their men were all about so they fired
their machine guns and rifles mainly
into the air
our attack lasted about 30 minutes we
had no casualties during the attack
two were killed during the counter
attacks
so that that that silent option
i was do we were doing training i was at
team two i was an assistant platoon
commander
they captured one of our seals they had
him up and this is an
urban combat training they had him up in
the third floor of this building
and they're telling you yell and scream
and so he's up there they're gonna kill
me and all this
and they're waiting for us and they're
waiting for us to do what we do which is
you know enter on the first floor clear
the first floor move the second floor to
the second floor move the third floor
and clear the third floor get to the
room where he is
and i'm like you know silence
we patrolled out we took the the fire
escape
up directly to the third floor didn't
clear any of the other rooms and went
right into where because we could see
where he was
we could hear where he was so we knew he
was in like one of one or two or three
rooms
and we caught those those op4 guys
completely off guard
they're they're they're literally
looking out the windows trying to see
where we were
and we walked in and shot them all in
the back rescued our guy
but the what's important here is and he
goes into
like a little bit of a little bit more
detail but you
because we're being quiet you have to
have good control lines of where you're
going to let people get to
hand-to-hand fighting
captain gerald infantry at biscari
airport i used my trench knife
twice one of my men got three with his
bayonet
he shot one then another tried to grab
his bayonet
he got this one with his bayonet that
got him started
so he got three in before it was all
over
small arms against armor we found that
the 30 caliber
ap pierces enemy armored half tracks at
close ranges
that's something that everybody should
know
platoon action lieutenant halridge
infantry
when the enemy machine guns opened up we
threw grenades
the machine guns pulled back out of
grenade fire
then ncos and browning automatic
riflemen went up over the embankment
through and beyond the initial enemy
positions eventually we had a base of
fire about 20 men
including the bars the bars during the
enemy counter attacks we did pretty well
with other fire two
lead was flying fast and furiously at 20
to 30 yards
we fire at flashes in this kind of
firing you learn to fire and roll to one
side or they will soon get you
i read that whole thing just to get that
last little part if you're a trooper out
there
if you're in the military you shoot and
then you move
because if you pop your head up again in
that same spot you're getting you're
gonna take one
comment in all these accounts of a
successful night attack
by a small unit the application of the
following principles
is worthy of note close control during
the approach by the use of control lines
adjusted to difficult terrain features
designation of a line of departure as
close to the objective as possible
and after all major terrain obstacles
have been passed
this is essential to assure proper
organization of the unit
immediately prior to this you can apply
that right there's so many business
things right there
like you get everything ready to go you
get past all the main obstacles
once everyone's passed the main
obstacles then you execute attainment of
the vital surprise
use of the bayonet and hand grenades
with no weapon firing permitted
it may often be advisable to prohibit
the loading of rifles and for anyone
that doesn't understand why these guys
are talking about using grenades so much
grenades do not give away your position
neither do bayonets
so you can hug grenades and no one knows
where it just came from there's no one
to shoot at there's no muzzle flash
and so it's a great weapon when you are
attacking from
like a clandestine situation where you
don't want the
enemy to know where you are use of
frontal attack only
any attempt at envelopment tends to
cause disorder and confusion note that
one platoon
which had advanced ahead of the general
lines was pulled back to conform
so they're saying frontal attack only
and what they're saying is
don't try and surround because if you
try and surround people at night and
you're gonna end up on opposite sides
and you're gonna end up in a
blue on blue situation i don't think
that they mean
don't set up flank situations
a definite and limited objective capture
of an airfield in this case
in which the entire front could be
covered by manpower rather than
firepower oh that's good
these are the major elements of
successful knight attack brought out in
the foregoing account others not
mentioned but which were undoubtedly
contributing contributing factors
of the operation are careful planning in
minute detail
precise specific orders careful
arrangement
for maintenance of direction thorough
daylight reconnaissance
by as many of the leaders as possible
use of compound use of compact columns
in the approach so the reason that
they're saying precise specific orders
that's different
that's different than what we normally
talk about the reason is because you are
attempting to make this happen
without having the enemy get a vote
so once the enemy gets a vote if you're
too specific things change now we don't
know what to do
but we are setting this thing up to be
very
specific and we should be able to get to
our last points of concealment
we should be in our positions everything
should be good once that
attack starts you know you still want to
keep them constrained because it's night
time
yeah and the context of the night piece
is also i think really important because
it seems what he's what they're saying
is that there's a lot more close control
under a knight attack it requires a
whole bunch of things because when the
chaos
ensues underneath tech you are denied
something that you usually rely on so
heavily
and when you were reading that and again
it's under the context of a night
assault it's different
it's different at night you told a story
long time ago that i've used a bunch and
there's a version of it i have from
flying which was
when we started using nvgs the way we
described the use of
nvgs why we would use nvgs in an
airplane
is the most simplest way to describe it
is it allows us to use
daytime tactics at night which before
you
just couldn't do you actually you want
the least amount of
close control as possible you need to
have some but in the day you don't need
it as much because you can rely on
being able to see each other and when
you started to see people like
reject the idea of things that allowed
you to maneuver in different ways
using technology because why would i do
it like that
the night creates an environment that's
really hard to operate in
and if you're going to be successful at
night you have to do a lot more things
than you would normally do during the
day which is why some of the technology
pieces are so nice to allow you to do it
but even with that you can't pretend
like the two are the same and
and the detail is going through i'm all
thinking like yeah you wouldn't do that
during the day
you have to do that at night yeah yeah
and now that we're talking about it
when you're talking about this size
element because i'm saying hey you could
still set up flanks
but if it's nighttime you got a big
element i actually wouldn't i would set
up a complete
online assault we would all be together
we would all be within you know
communication distance and we're gonna
not make those mistakes
and we're going to know where everyone
is because when you're online you've got
free fire at any direct
in 180 degrees ahead of you it's an
awesome thing that's gonna that's gonna
that's gonna overwhelm or or
make the idea of having another element
on the flank
obsolete because you because your
firepower is so unrestricted
when you're online and that's you know
it's like you can either sold online or
you can set up an l that's it and then
there's these little other variations
where you can start to envelop but
development is very very dangerous and
you better have some serious control
measures in place if you're going to try
that
very serious control measures including
up to and including
pieces of terrain that actually prevent
you from having a blue on blue because
there's a freaking
mountain or a ravine or a whatever that
prevents
you from getting shot by your own guys
all right this this little section here
starts to jump into really specific
stuff
knocking out pill boxes and then it gets
into
individual initiative
the following cases of individual
initiative initiative and heroism
during the salerno landing were reported
by
the infantry sergeant manuel
gonzalez upon landing discovered the
position of a german 88 in the sand
dunes near the beach
this gun was firing on the assault boats
as they landed
the sergeant crept around the position
under machine gun fire
which set his pack on fire
and despite the hand grenades being
thrown at him
he then calmly tossed several hand
grenades into a gun emplacement
killing the crew and blowing up their
ammunition
yeah you're going to see each one of
these these are talking about individual
initiative what they are
is just just pure heroics
sergeant john y mcgill jumped on an
enemy tank and dropped the hand grenade
into the open turret killing the crew
private clayton i tallman on hill 424
observed that the enemy was attempting
an envelopment of the left flank
of his company taking up a better
position he killed an enemy machine gun
crew with three carefully aimed shots
in a few minutes he repeated the same
action when another enemy machine gun
crew appeared
he alone protected the left flank of the
company until the rest of the platoon
arrived private burrell
b reich discovered that he and a group
of five men had been cut off from his
company
he immediately organized them into a
defensive position on a small null
they repulsed three rushes by the enemy
who were attempting to establish machine
gun positions on the flank
private reich was completely in command
of the situation giving orders and
shouting encouragement
yeah i was going off on the last podcast
about
having team members that are going to
step up and just make things happen
staff sergeant quillen h
mcmitchen was shot in the chest and
shoulder and shoulder before his assault
boat reached the shore
i say that again shot in the chest and s
and shoulder
before he reaches the shore have you
ever had a
shoulder injury echo charles uh yes yeah
where you're like ah you know i really
can't do anything
right right or you or you hurt your you
know you get somebody with that pulls
their pack muscle or whatever
yeah well what do they do for the next
six months they they they sit around and
drink warm milk
what does mcmitchen do well when the
boat reached the beach the landing ramp
stuck and would not drop the sergeant
despite his wounds kicked the ramp loose
and then led his section ashore
continuing to wreck their to direct
their operations
until he received a fatal shot from
enemy gunfire
pre-assault you get shot in the chest
and shoulder when you get shot in the
shoulder you're not using that arm and
then you get shot in the chest as well
our men moved ahead in the face of the
intense fire and cleared the beach as
soon as possible
lieutenant carey soon after reaching the
shore was fired upon by three germans
armed with machine pistols
he returned fire but his car being
jammed after killing one of the
of his adversaries he then grasped his
weapon
as a club and advancing in the face of
their
fire clubbed the second then
he physically tackled subdued and
disarmed the third german
taking him prisoner
the ability of the individual soldier to
grasp the implications of the situation
and take the necessary action should be
fully exploited
the results of combat are the fruits of
combined efforts of
individuals every soldier should be
indoctrinated with the idea
that his individual action may be the
decisive factor
in the final result
leadership strategy and tactic every guy
in the platoon is the most important guy
true statement true statement that that
comment
is so i mean it is so powerful
that they can that they understand that
what they do
individually can change the entire
outcome
of the entire operation and what's crazy
when i'm listening to these
these stories of just like you described
just total acts of heroism
they called it initiative inherently
what's crazy about that is for the ones
that have ended up
medal of honor awardees the ones that
end up telling their stories
they all say the exact same thing and
i'm paraphrasing but they all say
i don't feel like a hero i just doing my
job that's what they all say
they just have this simple way of
describing
i wasn't doing it to be a hero i needed
to take out that machine gun nest
tom fives like i i didn't think of it in
like any heroic
i i needed to blow up that tank so i got
out of the tank and took her
and they downplay it so much that when
you're listening to you're kind of just
in awe like bro are you
are you kidding me you're a total hero
but they never see it like that they're
just like
i had to do this my men needed me to do
this so i just did it
the last thing i was thinking about was
the write-up that i was going to get if
i
attacked this position and they do
things that just seem completely
superhuman and
the way they're able to do that is they
understand that what they do
has huge impact on the people around
them which is crazy you can teach that
to a human being
yeah imagine if you had a company where
every single person inside your company
thought that each individual action that
they had would have an
impact on the entire company as a whole
what if you could
indoctrinate and inculcate that idea
into your team imagine what that team
would be like
action on achoo operations report
regimental combat team
to fight the japs in this in this
country our troops must stick to high
ground
and not only outflank but out altitude
the enemy
the high ground continuous movement is
necessary to keep the spark in an attack
if a machine gun covers one point then a
group
not at that point must continue to
advance
when fire is shifted the original group
must move
even if the platoon is entirely halted
by the fire of enemy guns then the
commitment of additional troop
results whereas by proper coordination
some portion of the platoon can be kept
moving and the force
committed kept to a minimum
that's his number one thing is covered
move
the tendency of lower commanders to
commit reserves too early must be curbed
security cannot be overemphasized any
movement or group on the battlefield
even in a rear areas is subject to enemy
action
in this connection consideration must be
given to the protection of medical
installation
at present these are left unprotected
without even
individual arms for their personnel in
the event of enemy penetration through
our front line positions
it is practically certain that these
installations will be hit why are they
given that lessons because that's
exactly what happened on like a suicide
attack
from the japanese aggressive patrolling
particularly to maintain
active content contact is of vital
importance it can mean the difference
between defeat and victory
however mere numbers of patrols will not
solve the problem
special training in patrolling and
organizing patrols must be initiated
commanders must plan to have reasonably
fresh men
available for night contact it is vital
to organize patrol activity carefully
to ensure that all lines are familiar
with the roots
returning of returning patrols so that
the danger of mistaken identity and in
the darkness will be minimized
yeah they got the the japanese on their
attack made it
they broke through and it was fighting
in the rear
lieutenant general simon b buckner
commanding general alaskan department
it was apparent that the enemy was
particularly vulnerable to attack by
units of our infantry which pushed
forward vigorously
while the enemy was held down by
artillery fire what do we call that
recovered move
those units which had learned to advance
closely behind their own artillery
supporting fire
had the greatest success the japs do not
like our coordinated
artillery fire nor do they like our
attacks with a bayonet
when under fire from small arms they
stay down in their holes and are easily
approached
when attacking small groups of foxholes
our troops were able to keep the japs
down by fire from rifles and the
browning automatic rifle
while some of our men approached and
dropped hand grenades into their holes
this is our favorite mop up method cover
move
when about to be run out of a position
the jab seemed to feel it necessary to
counter attack these attacks were not
well coordinated and were welcomed by
our troops who were able to shoot down
that enemy in great numbers these jap
counter-attacks were part
of a suicidal character and were pressed
home regardless of losses until
practically all the counter-attract
counter-attacking troops were
exterminated
the enemy may believe that in such
terrain he can hold up the advance of an
entire
battalion with three men and a light
machine gun
in fact however he is critically
vulnerable to intelligent action by
officers and men who understand the
necessity
for immediate maneuver against small
parties of the enemy
seeking to hold them up the fact was
that a small maneuvering
that small maneuvering patrols easily
disposed of machine gun positions on
reverse slopes behind mountain spurs
whereas any tendency to lie down and
call for artillery support
would have resulted only in tremendous
wastage of artillery fire
and attempting to seek out targets which
in fact were inaccessible to artillery
fire
that's an important point so you think
oh we got a machine gun up there
uh we need to call for fire and now you
think about how hard it's going to be
for this artillery to hit this place
that's bunkered in or they're on the
reverse slope of a mountain or whatever
it's a real problem and yet these guys
realized if they just
aggressively maneuvered on that machine
gun they'd be able to take it out
the two action likewise indicated
that standard japanese infiltration
tactics can be offset by a system of
anti-termite patrols organized behind
our lines protecting artillery command
posts and supply lines
wherever troops know that these friendly
patrols
were behind them fire in our rear will
mean simply that our patrols are
cleaning people up
goes into the south pacific talking
about the jungle jungle notes aggressive
action flexible
plans
report of the 43rd division new georgia
aggressive action is necessary
never relax the pressure
never relax the pressure that's a good
that's a good just thing to think about
every time you wake up in the morning
never relax the pressure maneuver of
small units at risk of temporary loss
of communications is important plans and
orders must be
so flexible as to permit prompt maneuver
change this is another thing where i
would feel like i was cheating when i
was
you know going through training and
stuff because
we would make these really flexible
plans and and of course the training
cadre is gonna do things to disrupt your
plan
and when your plan gets disrupted and
it's super flexible you're like oh
whatever
you know go with plan b go with plan c
no factor
never relax the pressure it's actually
pretty hard to disrupt a plan
that's not very original you know yeah
we didn't have like
37 steps that you can interrupt we had a
basic idea and some real good ideas of
how we're going to maneuver
and disrupting that's much harder
dude that that that last one was awesome
which one
the the one you talked about never never
over relaxed the pressure
yeah like but i think the title of that
was um aggressive action flexible plans
whatever that title was just that alone
obviously the description makes it even
better but that in and of itself
that will solve just that mindset
solves so many problems in your world
anywhere in your world
there's a couple things that you need to
be aware of the way that you
have flexible plans is you are
religious about making sure everyone
understands the commander's intent
that's if you can do that hey this is
what this is the overall thing that
we're trying to accomplish
here's the couple parameters you got to
work within other than that
make it happen yeah get aggressive
making it happen
because if you just make a flexible plan
and you think hey you know you guys come
in from the west and you guys come in
from the south
there's all kinds of things that go
wrong with that plan it's super flexible
but no one knows where they can go where
they can't go
there's no deconfliction set up so you
need to think about it
the other thing that's interesting about
aggressive action flexible plans is
the more you plan the more detail you
get the worse your plan becomes
now if you come up with a plan in three
minutes you probably need a little bit
more time
although i have executed operations
where i we planned for
15 minutes my boss asked me that my boss
said how much time do you guys need to
launch this is my first deployment
my second deployment no one asked me if
they already knew the answer
uh my first book how much time do you
guys need i was like
15 minutes that's how much time
what you're getting at though is the
propensity of how do things usually
work out do we usually plan too much or
not enough
it's pretty rare that we don't plan
enough what typically happens is we over
plan and over
plan an overplan and there's an old
saying i don't know if it's just in
aviation is how long
do you have to plan your mission and the
joke is 30 mi how long do you need to
plan your mission and the joke is 30
minutes more than you have
and the reason is is we have a
propensity to over plan
oh you guys say that in aviation yeah i
thought i made that up you did not make
it up
unless it was on your trip to fallon and
all of a sudden you're the reason we
said now we've been saying that for
years
and the point is kind of what you're
getting at is oh if you gave me nine
hours of plan guess how long i'm gonna
plan
nine hours can you underplan yes
you absolutely can you can plan for two
minutes when you actually need to spend
some more time
but the driver is is what you were
saying is hey i only need 15 minutes i
need to cover the key points the
highlights and if you've got a team
that's well trained
they might even recognize hey you listen
we got a little additional risk here
because we didn't really have time to
dissect this one so when we get to this
place in the mission
we need to be a little more aware that
we're going to need to be a little more
flexible we have
we're less aware than we like to be but
i know that as opposed to
hey let's take three days to plan by the
time i get to the objective it's a total
waste of time because
because that mission has come and gone
most teams that we work with
over plan they overthink they over
create and then when they go out to
implement
they're either too late or they're so
rigid in what they do
they can't maneuver around so if you're
looking for the balance there
less is typically more not always not a
hundred percent of the time
but that's where your buyer should be
yeah it's kind of like packing right
for a trip it's kind of the same mindset
which is
like over packing people will over pack
because they think of
all the different scenarios they're
gonna need this jacket those socks
this shoe i need flip-flops too for that
you see what i'm saying
meanwhile you got to wash your dryer
there you know you don't need all that
stuff you got to be flexible
see what i'm saying otherwise you got
all these suitcases you know
it's the same mindset as what i'm saying
though yeah what i'm saying yeah like if
you
under pack but you're flexible it's way
better
yeah maneuver you can maneuver you know
yeah it is weird that
it's such an advantage to come up with a
nice flexible plan
that everybody knows and it's so easy
man the the planning the planning
what would i call it like the the
evolution of planning inside the seal
teams
you know at one point it was beyond
insanity we
wrote about it in in extreme ownership i
mean the way seth
and leif were taught to plan was was
mayhem
it was it was 150 slide power points
yeah that you know oh and your fonts
wrongly
you need to go through this branch plan
and this other thing over here
man when those guys started working with
me i remember
when when i and i talked about this in
extreme ownership
when i was telling those guys hey just
make a plan
that the lowest common denominator out
get up have people walk through it look
at the map
use the map draw a picture draw it up on
the whiteboard
do that i remember seth was looking at
me
like he was gonna get fired like when he
gives this brief
he's gonna get fired and it's funny
because usually i would get that
i would feel a little bit more pushback
from life
on stuff and seth would be like yeah
roger and leif would be like why would
you like that
and this time for whatever reason i
think i think leif actually just
realized
that this was the smartest thing he'd
ever heard i think leif just said to
himself
you know what this actually freaking
makes sense and he was so
on board with it he was so stoked and he
had and he had
btf tony was his chief and that's the
way you know tony knew how to make shit
happen
and and i just but but seth was just
freaked out like well
i mean you think he was so freaked out
by the fact of thinking that he was
gonna get fired for
for trying to make his men understand
what was going to happen on this mission
and the cool thing was the commanding
officer when when they got done
because it was two platoons going out on
on an sr you know on a reconnaissance
mission
and they both took their platoons out
when they got done the the
you know the the commanding officer who
had gone around and watched all the
platoons give all their briefs
and give all these 150 powerpoint slides
and do all these
you know uh what is it called animation
in your slides
he'd watched all those things and he he
said these are these are the best briefs
i've seen
which was freaking awesome it was
awesome because
if the commanding officer can't follow
what the hell is going to happen on
operation
how is a new guy e4 machine gunner can
he's not following anything
and the more flexible you make these
plans when you're not all rigid
what's kind of crazy about that is that
commanding officer was probably stoked
that the brief took
nine minutes not 49 minutes he was
probably waiting like here we go
yeah we're gonna come in and and he
would probably look down like that's it
that's awesome
yeah i mean it was you know is it still
an hour long yeah
uh but an hour long of real information
as opposed to you know an hour and 47
minutes
of slides that are of of you know
uh asset matrix for the where he knew
represented 30 man hours of
powerpoint work to make the arrow move
the the point behind that was
and i saw this in the pentagon all the
time i wouldn't be surprised if you saw
some of this
in the ea world working in you know with
admirals and generals is
we create this thing where we are
hey this is how the boss wants it oh
yeah and so we give the boss what he
wants and some of the bosses are pretty
they don't want to go down their
micromanager people so they kind of
tolerate it
and we convince ourselves this is what
the boss is looking for so i'm going to
do
what make most of our bosses don't
actually want this they just want to
make sure they know that you know what
you're going to go do
to go get it done and the least amount
of time it takes to make him comfortable
that you know the plan is actually what
he wants
and i remember putting these briefs
together and i'd get these templates to
go brief these generals up in the top
floor of the pentagon it was this big
thing you've got 19 minutes get to
fitness calendar
and we go in there and for the first
couple briefs we'd have
47 pages and he'd go hey can you just
skip to the summary slide
click click click click click click
click click click summary he's like
okay okay hey that make hey bullet
through what do you mean by that hey sir
we're talking about this okay cool
awesome hey i hate to do it to you guys
i gotta get going thanks but i'm good
you're playing go execute
they didn't want any of that garbage but
we followed this template we were so
sure that they wanted
most leaders really just want to know
that you understand
yeah and they want to understand the
wave tops of what's happening so they
understand
i had this guy who was putting up i was
putting a group through land warfare
and this guy gave a brief and it was
horrible and long and
freaking too detailed and covered stuff
that didn't matter to anyone in the room
and then he gave another brief that was
you know not enough and
you know skipped like basic
contingencies
and and then he was kind of frustrated
and he goes
can you even tell me what a good brief
is
as if that was like a trick question you
know i was i thought about it for
four seconds and i said a good brief
is a brief where your men understand
what is going to happen
and what to do during an operation
that's a good brief
and he was able to dial it in yeah
this we're in the jungle you might have
forgot that patrolling in the jungle an
officer
with considerable experience in the
jungle patrolling gives this advice
patrols are most likely to give away
their presence in an area
by their footprints shine from the
smallest metal surface such as a belt
buckle or watch must be avoided
a luminous watch constitutes a real
danger
any noise such as talking coughing
spitting etc must has to be treated with
the greatest of all dangers
a man on patrol must learn to move
silently making every possible use of
natural cover
that's just old school stuff i got to
feel some of that when i was hunting
i was like so happy to be moving quietly
some more patrol tips positioning
camouflage are more important than i
learned in the states
in training in training bear down
on cover and concealment bear down on
avoidance of the blundering approach
on patrols on fire maneuver which are
equally
important i didn't read that well in
training
bear down on cover and concealment bear
down on the avoidance of blundering
approach
on patrols on fire maneuver
which are equally important
size of patrols lieutenant colonel
w.a walker tank destroyer battalion
commander tunisia
which you know let's just face it if
you're getting a title tank destroying
battalion commander is right up there
many men were lost in tunisia by using
squad patrols the germans used
stronger patrols and just gobbled them
up a patrol should be
either a sneak patrol small enough to
escape detection
or a combat patrol large enough to fight
its way out of difficulty
never allow one man to go out alone
you know what's interesting about that
we don't want to be balanced right
well it's not going to want to be
balanced but what he's saying is like
you either
want to be small and maneuverable and
quiet or big enough to fight
don't don't don't try and make the
mistake of trying to do both
hey we'll just take out a squad plus
then you're making a bunch of noise
the difference between you know
six guys and
12 guys is a massive difference
it is a massive difference on a patrol
it's a totally
like when we go out of the squad patrol
in in the seal teams you know you got
eight guys
it's this tiny little thing and you can
see everyone in
at night with no night vision you can
see everyone there
you when you take out a platoon patrol
it seems like you've got this just
massive thing and when you take out a
task unit patrol it's
just freaking gigantic like they're gone
i hear you
don't make that mistake so this is one
of those things that's like it's not a
dichotomy either or one of those rare
things
yeah because normally we're saying hey
you know don't go to the extreme one
side or the other
right you want to be balanced yeah this
is so you might fall into
the trap of well i want them to be small
enough to be light nimble but big enough
where you know they can defend
themselves and what you're going to end
up with is not small and light and not
able to defend themselves
right like not not big enough to fight
yet not small enough to move yes it's
kind of like
when you surf obviously it's kind of
like when you judge waves right
you're either too far for it to crash on
you or you just go
100 under the wave you know what i'm
saying otherwise it crashes on you you
either go over it
or under it under it or it crashes way
before it can hit you
oh that's that's a positive thing yes
you don't want it to crash on you on you
yes you are you want to be in that one
that little middle ground you don't want
to be
in the in the zone of destruction yeah
the red zone there's a movie called the
north shore
the impact zone impact zone yeah so
north shore he covered that
yeah he was like yeah you're like you
don't want to be actually this guy
turtle doesn't have you ever watched
north shore did burke
no yeah rick kane anyway guy from
arizona wins a tank
surfing competition so he's like of
course i'm going to the north shore so
he was kind of a tank destroyer
in a matter of speaking yes nonetheless
tank waves are pretty small
and tame you know the artificial waves
in arizona apparently
so he goes to the north shore and you
know he kind of gets wrecked for a
little bit anyway he meets the sky
turtle and turtle says
if the wave is here don't be here
because you're gonna get drilled
classic line man so same deal in this
maybe we should cover
that movie on here just to get these
make sure we pass on these
lessons learned i'm just saying these
concepts are everywhere that's
that's the thing next section is called
infantry weapons goes through detail m1
rifle frag grenades
the thompson submachine gun the browning
automatic
rifle the light machine got heavy
machine gun 60 millimeter mortar 81
millimeter mortar
the 37 millimeter at gun
the 4.2 inch chemical mortar
which was originally called that because
it was originally made for
firing chemical shells but eventually
they adjusted it put hg in there
but they still called it the uh so it
goes through like really good
kind of pragmatic details of on how to
operate those weapons
talks about next sections about
artillery
wait what's chemical mortar chemical
motors we're gonna fire well what they
disguised it was was this is a smoke
mortar
yeah so we're gonna shoot if we have to
use smoke
to you know cover movement or we want to
disrupt
the enemy's ability to see we have a
mortar for firing smoke
but that was really so we could fire
chemical weapons
if we were going to use them like well
like to hear nerve gas or something like
this yeah like oh damn yeah like you're
gonna die
but we didn't do that we ended up making
an he round high expos which is kind of
a normal mortar round for it
and they liked it uh
a section called mast fires lieutenant
colonel james
infantry cicely our division artillery
was never out of support for more than
five minutes throughout the whole
campaign
we've got a wonderful set of battalions
in our division artillery and we have
worked so
closely together that they're as much
part of our outfit as our own battalions
they kept they keep right up on our
heels all the time
and that is just what we've got to have
i don't know what we could have done
without them
they leap frogged their batteries
continually and went into some of the
damnedest positions i had ever seen
and delivered the goods we just can't
praise them too much
they were always right there when you
needed them in one place where we
couldn't get forward because the high
knees were on superior ground
and had us pinned down with rifle
machine gun and mortar fire the division
artillery masked
nine batteries on them and plastered
them with
1500 rounds in less than 30 minutes
we then walked through that position
without a scratch and the german dead
were all over the place
teamwork infantry tank team captain
putman
putnam infantry sicily the infantry
should be given practical training in
cooperation with tanks i don't mean the
armored infantry
they're part of the armored division and
work with them all the time i mean
ordinary infantry like us
i know our regiment didn't have any
training with tanks in preparation for
combat
we just didn't know how to work with the
attached tank unit when the jerk when
the tanks came up to support us after we
had broken up
the german attack we did not follow up
the tanks properly as they went forward
had we done so we could have cleaned out
most of the battalion of germans
we had not been trained to work with the
tanks and when we remained in position
they went
and we remained in position after they
went forward if we would have known how
to go forward with them
we could have done a much better job and
could have gotten all the german
vehicles
and materiel after this experience we
strongly recommend that
all infantry be given practical training
and cooperation with tanks
in action get the infantrymen used to
the tanks and how to fight together with
them
that that for me that's a a comment
about training
in general you know you can't expect
people to do things that they've never
trained to do
so don't expect them to do things that
they haven't tried to do if there's
something that they need to know how to
do
that they might have to do train them on
it
infantry tank attack lieutenant colonel
perkins tank battalion commander italy
the rush to battle is the wrong idea
here we creep up each tank should
overwatch another tank each section
should overwatch another section
each platoon should overwatch another
platoon
ranger training buddy system
lieutenant colonel william o darby
commanding officer of the rangers in
italy and i think everybody
kind of knows what i say when i say
lieutenant lieutenant colonel william oh
darby i know they at least think of the
darby queen
the the ranger obstacle course in our
work we always use the buddy system
the men work in pairs they live in pairs
eat in pairs do garden pairs even do kp
in pairs confidence in each other is
developed
they can pick their own buddy from
within their platoon
same thing in the seal teams day one you
get a swim buddy and you stick with them
realism in our training we never do
anything without battle noises and
effects we always use live
ammunition we use mines barbed wire and
protective bands of machine gun fire
extensively
if the problem is to capture a machine
gun nest there's always a machine gun
nest there with a machine gun firing in
a fixed direction
the men very quickly get accustomed to
having live ammunition flying around
them
captured italian and german machine guns
and machine pistols are used by the
enemy
in our problems that he's talking about
the op for our men quickly learn to
distinguish between the fire of our own
weapons and that of enemy weapons
also the enemy makes constant use of
flares
we always carry our normal load of
ammunition with weapons loaded
if a man knows his weapon is loaded he
will be more careful in handling it an
accidental discharge of a weapon
automatically means a fine and immediate
reduction to the grade of private
in our work we must take drastic
measures to guard against accidental
discharges of weapons
we learned our lesson in tunisia where
the accidental discharge of a rifle
cleared a raid and caused a 24-hour
delay in operations
so all kinds of good stuff in there and
and
i will say this so when i got the steel
teams it was almost all live fire
we did live fire for everything and it
gave you that kind of pressure and that
kind of
you got accustomed to machine guns and
hearing them and you know round snapping
overhead and
you just got used to it in fact there
were days where they would put us down
range
and just shoot you know put put you down
range you'd go behind a berm or whatever
you get in a safe spot
and then they just shoot at you so you
start getting used to like okay
this is what different rounds sound like
and you know that happens even being in
the butts at uh
you know on a normal range but that kind
of realism is important
here's the drawback the drawback is the
enemy doesn't maneuver the enemy doesn't
shoot back at you
so when we started using simunition
paintball laser tag systems that
totally improved our tactical capability
to to an incredible amount the
accidental discharge that's still a huge
deal right
oh yeah what is it now like that i mean
they're they're talking about finding
people and busting them down to private
uh i mean it i i think some of it
depends on the circumstances you know if
you have an actual discharge in the seal
teams it's going to be
your careers your career is on the line
you know if you if you have something
like that happen it's not necessarily
going to be over yeah but you're going
to have a real
you know you're going to have to keep
your hopes up
that you don't that you don't get so
even like um
like a they call it a d right or uad
nd which is a negligent discharge are
those two different things
i think they are now i'm not i'm not
like totally caught up on the
on the um terminology of where it's at
right now
the nd just started coming around when i
was
sort of in my later years
yeah um yeah i feel like negligent
that's like careless you know yeah
so like an accidental discharge which to
your point
you can have you can have a round just
cook off like you're out in the desert
in imperial valley in california it's
120 degrees out
and you dump six mags on your last run
and you're standing there your weapon is
scorching hot and if there's a round in
the chamber it can cook off
it can just shoot that's why you have
your weapons painted pointed in a safe
direction
at all times if that happened
you you're not gonna get i mean you know
you're not really gonna get in trouble i
mean
if everyone didn't have their weapon
clear and safe but when it's hot out
everyone'd be like hey claire and save
your weapons
but you know we also used to have a
command safe and let them hang which is
just you just
save your weapon and you just let it
hang there so if you've got a hot round
in there it can cook off
you're probably not you know you're not
gonna get in trouble for that most
likely
you occasionally a weapon will have some
kind of a malfunction
that will cause a problem um
what else could happen i feel like
something like that like a weapons
malfunction
you know yeah that's like that's an
accident negligent is the kind like
i had my finger in the trigger yeah and
you know somebody called a ceasefire
and all of a sudden you know i kind of
let my weapon hang and it's resting on
my finger and i crack off around
right you're gonna get a lot of trouble
for that yeah
interesting this is more on ranger
training
physical conditioning one of our best
means of physical conditioning is speed
marching
finally reaching a point where we march
10 miles at a rate of 6 miles an hour to
keep in condition we use calisthenics
and a daily
five mile speed march
discipline disciplinary drills
are all important we have a retreat
formation daily
conditions permitting at this formation
the men are inspected
and some manual of arms performed
followed by retreat every sunday morning
there is a review followed by inspection
of the ranks
and then inspection of the camp
recorders we have at least four periods
a week of closed order drill
and manual of arms and one period every
week devoted to military courtesy
infractions of discipline military
courtesy and uniform regulations are
dealt with
quickly and severely the officers must
bear down on these things the army in
general has not stressed
strict discipline enough without it you
are lost
yeah one of those things um
can you go too far with discipline dave
burke yes you can
absolutely i mean i obviously don't know
the background of that story but
you know the version of the story he's
talking about is the guys that could
field strip your weapon in the dark at
night
on the worst possible situations we had
nine seconds to get that weapon back in
action
you need discipline and repeat and wrote
and over
you need that and then the flip side is
exactly what you started this whole
conversation with if i just
if i if you do it because you're scared
of me and i
tell you to do it because if you don't
you're going to get punished sooner or
later
sooner or later that approach will fail
and
look i know what the context of this
book is so it's driven by that first
scenario but you absolutely can overdo
it
yeah and then you could be like john
bazzalone
bazzy and you'd hear stories hear
stories
from guys that worked with him and
they absolutely loved
doing the right thing drilling with
those weapons
he set the example he did it in front of
them at night
blindfold all those things he did all
those things he did and he
like they loved doing it he was
inspirational
he didn't impose discipline on them he
showed them
and gave them the gift of
self-discipline
which is far superior dude and think of
the mileage you get
is if as a leader the discipline that
you demand from your people
and the punishment that might come from
not doing it if you actually impose it
upon yourself
as well and hold yourself to the same
standard as opposed to
get out there and go do that and i'm
going to sit in here and i don't know
watch tv or something that piece of it
when you're talking about that
discipline
what you get when you hold yourself to
the exact same standard people
bazzy
section two field artillery morale
effect the incessant
firing of our artillery during the six
week
period produced contrasting effects on
the nerves of our own troops and on
those the enemy
our infantry often stated that having
those rounds continually landing in
front of them was one of the best morale
builders especially at night
in the jap on the other hand it produced
severe cases of war neurosis
he couldn't sleep at night because he
never knew when
or where the next round was going to
land
he couldn't sleep in the daytime because
when our infantry wasn't attacking him
our artillery was giving him hell
and this is nice the following
statements made by prisoners
are interesting so these are japanese
prisoners of which we know there wasn't
a lot
between the airport between
b below hill and the airport we had many
guns of all sizes
before this campaign but now many of
them are gone
knocked out by artillery it has
completely demoralized many units
reduced many units in strength and has
made many men
go crazy we were awakened at night by
the slightest noise
because of the bad state of nerves at
night
three men stayed in one foxhole two
smoked while one slept
during the day we also tried to get some
sleep by alternating
but the continual artillery fire kept us
on edge
and we got no rest even in the two-story
dugouts
many men were killed just by concussion
a direct hit would kill
all the men inside the artillery is the
one thing
that is universally feared by all our
ground troops
it continues over such long periods of
time and the rounds come
so fast except for the artillery
we could continue our defense
that's horror that's just horror
section three miscellaneous booby traps
seventh army report sicily a german
luger pistol was booby trapped on a
table
new replacement picked it up two were
killed and 14 were wounded in the
resulting explosion
there's another little site i mean i
wasn't going to read this but i'm going
to read it a luger pistol was found
lying on the ground an american infantry
lieutenant carefully tied a long cord to
it and then getting into a hole
pulled it to him and put it in his
pocket later in the day while examining
the pistol he attempted to remove the
magazine
the explosion killed the lieutenant and
two other men with six soldiers wounded
the reason i'm reading that is because
that was a freaking they set that thing
up
uh that's a that's a massive explosion
from a
small piece of from a small pistol
timeliness of orders major kinney
infantry our chief difficulty throughout
the campaign was the lack of time given
for the execution of orders frequently
we received
operations orders which did not allow
enough time for proper preparation
preparation and execution
at san fratello we received an order
after 11
p.m to attack at 6 00 a.m the next
morning
now when i read that i was like hey man
i was kind of thinking
i've come up with a simple flexible plan
no factor i got this what are they
whining about
read on the six battalions were assembly
were in assembly areas
some five or six miles from the line of
departure
so even to get to where they were
supposed to leave from they had to go
six miles
the terrain over which they had to move
to get in position in the dark was the
roughest most
rugged mountain country you could
imagine and all ammunition weapons and
supplies
had to be taken by hand and by mule pack
although it might seem that 11 p.m to 6
a.m with sufficient time the actual
conditions were such that it was less
than
half then enough because the terrain
darkness and transport difficulties also
the men had just completed marches
over mountain trails of 9 to 14 miles
and we're not
fresh for the new movement
maps 7th army report sicily instill in
all personnel and appreciation of the
value of maps
the supply of maps will never be
adequate to the demand
training in the care and preservation of
maps is as important as training in the
care and preservation of materiel
most important thing you need to know
most important piece of information is
where you are
and if your map is destroyed have you
ever seen those old school silk maps
yes things are like yeah they print them
on silk echo
charles because then they could survive
i understand
i like this section this section is
called room for improvement
the following comments indicating
weaknesses which must be corrected
were made by the commanding general and
they don't give the division
i guess they're keeping it secret here
we go
sometimes units failed to dispose
themselves properly for all round
defense when halted on an objective or
when placed
in position for defense
so when you go into defense they're not
putting themselves in the right
positions
next in the attack rifleman frequently
failed to provide fire that would cover
the movement of adjacent units merely
because they were not able to pinpoint
definitely the location of the enemy
rifle and machine gun elements firing on
our troops
what does that mean that means you fire
where you suspect the enemy will be
and that's something that infantry men
and special operations people learn
is if you don't know where the enemy is
and you're in a gunfight shoot where you
think they might be
this is perhaps one of my favorite
things from this book
some small unit commanders selected
positions
apparently with cover and concealment
for themselves as the primary objective
rather than positions from which
effective fire could be brought to bear
on the enemy
and the last one due to the enormous
division frontage in the second phase of
the landing at salerno
some company some company some
commanders attempted to stretch their
units excessively
and as a result permitted faulty
dispositions
prioritize and execute
they go into some details on the
japanese overall
and you know i've been i've been reading
the book and saying japs
i know that's a derogatory term
towards japanese people i'm not
referring to japanese people i'm
referring to the
imperial japanese army members that were
fighting against america and were being
referred to
by their sworn enemy the americans as
japs
superman myth exploded that's the title
of this
operations report 43rd division new
georgia
our troops here came to regard the
superman stories about the japanese as
ridiculous
the jap is tricky but not so tricky as
many have led
been led to believe he is not he is not
nearly so ingenious or adaptable as the
average american
and the truth of the matter is he's
afraid of us
of our artillery and of our sea and air
power
our troops must learn this and never
forget it
this is the last i think it's the last
the last note
and this gives some stuff about the
japanese
as an enemy and then it gives some stuff
about the germans as an enemy
and this is the last one here last one
from this book
from part one of combat lessons
minor tactics staff sergeants richard e
deland and robert j kemp infantry
sicily never let
an apparently lone machine gun suck you
into a trap
the germans will usually not fire on the
individual but will wait
watch where he goes and get a whole
flock
and that's that's the last point in here
and i think it's a it's not the last
point in this whole
book there's a few more but i think it's
a good place to stop and the reason why
i think it's a good place to stop
is because it's a warning
it's a warning about a trap it's a
warning about a trap that the germans
use
which is you know put a lone looking
machine gun out there by itself oh
that looks exposed
and it seems real obvious when you read
it you're like hey if i see it looks too
good to be true
right this is too good to be true this
is the situation
and so it's real obvious to anyone
that's looking at it oh no that's too
good to be true
there's a a ripe machine gun
that's waiting to be taken out looks
real obvious
an obvious trap and yet the warning is
there
why is the warning still there because
people
still fall for it you will still fall
for it i will still fall for it we will
all
still fall for that trap
just like we will fall for the trap
that we're good to go that we know
everything that we need to know that we
understand everything that we need to
understand
that we have reached our
highest possible form
and all those little thoughts
are a trap
because we're not good and we don't know
everything we don't understand
everything and we have
absolutely not reached our highest form
we all have work to do so
watch out for that trap because it is
enticing
it is enticing like a lone machine gun
just kind of sitting out there by itself
waiting to be taken out
and it's real easy to tell yourself
that you're good so here's a little
warning for all of us
especially me
we can't fall for that trap
well that wraps up that
any other notes dave
no we addressed all of it that i wrote
down and a whole lot more
you know they're these lessons
all those statements the comments the
the explanations
they all come from the same place as
that trap they're all lessons learned
the hard way and as repetitive as they
sort of sound
they're all because all of those are the
same thing i'm going to say this over
and over and over again
because this keeps happening over and
over and over again and it's
in some ways it's it's heartbreaking but
that is the reality is that
even those lessons of the things we're
supposed to do come from
we had a saying in aviation they come
they were written in blood
they all came from a lesson that's
already been we already know that
but we learned it the hard way and
you you you repeat yourself all the time
and i don't mean that about you repeat
yourself we do an echelon front we
repeat ourselves all the time we take
the same thing and then try to
apply the context to whatever world
whatever company whatever business
whatever problem we're dealing with
but we're always saying the same thing
because these lessons
these lessons get learned over and over
and over again
and the biggest the biggest thing that
prevents us from making that lesson
stick
is what you just said is ourselves going
oh no
i got it i've heard it enough i
understand it and the minute
you are convinced that you've heard it
enough and you've got it is when you're
going to learn the exact same lesson
again
yeah it's weird
how i mean this happens to us all the
time in echelon front
you you go we go into a company the
company is in the game
they're in the game they're they're
telling me
i mean there's definitely people uh it
happens on ef online somebody would
bring something up and somebody's like
oh
jocko podcast number 128. yeah he talks
about that
i i don't know off top my head but
someone's answering that question in a
millisecond
right people that know the material so
we go into companies where
they know they've read they know
they wrote memorized i guess no is a
strong word right
uh but and i talked about this on
daryl cooper and i gotta got into it a
little bit
on the unraveling podcast
because he was saying to me well how do
you handle something when you
know that the other person's premise is
wrong
and you know he was pretty dug in
and i said well do you
actually really know that because i'm
not going to approach anything
if dave burke comes to me and says hey
jocko
a ufo just touched down in my backyard
i need support here asap
right not to split hairs but you mean
extraterrestrial what did i say
ufo okay yeah ufo's just unidentified
okay so he identified so he calls me up
and says a uh unidentified
extraterrestrial machine just landed
in my backyard
do what do i say look i know that's not
true or do i
right you know what i say i say well
what does it look like what what
what sort of what sort of weaponry do
you see do
are they is there a covering element can
you extract from the ao
until we can assemble a counter force to
go after these guys
right i don't just say hey dave shut up
yeah you know what i hate bringing up
i'm like that's a dumb example right but
it's really hard for me to think of
something that
i i should say it's really hard it's not
man people think that they know stuff
all the time oh yeah
and when i say on ef online the other
day i said don't mistake
your opinion for the truth
don't mistake your opinion for the truth
don't mistake
people's don't mistake what you've heard
and what you've said for the truth don't
mistake the way you've always done
things for the truth
don't mistake your perspective for the
truth
and that is why when you speak the truth
and you and i talked about this the
other day dave
when you speak the truth what you should
do is speak the truth humbly
from a place of humility speak the truth
from a place
of humility that's how you speak the
truth
because even when you believe something
and you quote
know it's right there is a chance and
you need to open your mind to this
chance that you
are actually wrong and you didn't
understand something you didn't
understand a different perspective
and all those things all those things of
you know thinking that you know thinking
that you don't make this mistake
all those things thinking that you're
that your opinion is the truth
all those things those are all traps
those are all just traps and they seem
so obvious when we're sitting here
talking about them
and yet day after day after day you you
see people fall into those traps
and so what's interesting is when we
talk about these lessons and where i was
starting this little idea is that you
and i work with companies all the time
and they know the material they can
recite the material
and yet they're caught up they're not
detached
and they're not executing correctly and
so
one of the primary things and it's great
being an echelon front because when we
come in
we are instantly where d we are detached
that's that's our function so as soon as
we just take them and
and we move them over to our position
three feet and say look at that meeting
look at how that meeting just went
or you know look at this look at this
this this task the way you put this out
to the troops look at this
just look at it does that sound like
you're micromanaging
does that sound like you're not giving
any ownership like what does it sound
like if you read this
and all of a sudden people go
so you've got to watch out for these
traps in the world
i'm going to say something that's a
total contradiction
because all the things that you
all these quotes all these lessons all
the things you were just reading about
in that in this book or whatever this is
this this compilation of people's
lessons that they've learned
i was thinking about how often these
things
get repeated it was this idea of hey the
minute you think you
know these lessons the minute you think
you i know this
is when you actually are have the most
amount of risk
and at the same time i'm thinking myself
i wish i knew
all this stuff at the very beginning of
my career and to think about
what i actually could have done with my
time in the marine corps
if i knew this stuff and
like just the ultimate dichotomy of
you never know this stuff you have to
learn it over and over again and if i
just knew this stuff
how much better i would have been at
what i was doing
the the broad understanding of it
is is what people
is what makes it hard for people to
understand at a level where it can be
utilized
because i know for a fact
that you were taught you know hey okay
when you're going through the basics
we'll be like okay you got this element
over here they're going to put down
you were absolutely taught that i was
absolutely taught that
and yet i ended up having to teach this
stuff to
seals guys that have been in for 15
years 20 years
to be like hey why aren't you putting
some machine guns out on the flanks
while you cross this road oh this is an
old school thing no it's actually cover
and move
this is a basic thing that we do all the
time
you know and i'm not saying every seal
but i'm just saying
seals that had been in the in the navy
for
a long time and
that that's what's so difficult about
these things and i was thinking about
this the other day
you start okay when you do jiu-jitsu
you're at a jiu-jitsu academy
and you the more people that are at the
academy
and the better they get it's like a
pyramid if you're at the top of the
pyramid so dean lister
is at the top of the pyramid at victory
mma
every single time someone shows up new
they're a white belt when they show up
here and they take their first class
that pyramid gets a little bit taller
and dean lister gets a little bit better
from one person showing up here because
that one person's going to train in a
different way and he's going to
prop up somebody else and that little
movement raises everyone up by the time
it gets to me i'm going up a little bit
and then dean's going up just getting a
little bit better
so what happens i think is these ideas
when you first hear them they're just
sort of there and you don't connect them
and then as you start to connect them
together
all of a sudden well not all of a sudden
as you start to connect them together
they start getting taller and taller and
taller and taller
and you start to see more connections
and really for me this is it does boil
down to
what made me start to connect these
things was jiu jitsu
and the fact that i could see in jiu
jitsu what i saw people supposed to do
in the battlefield those were the first
two connections that i made
and and it's probably because i heard it
somewhere i'm sure somebody said you
know martial arts are like
combat i'm like what does that mean or
whatever but then i started seeing the
actual connection between the two and
then at some point
i started seeing that oh those same
things actually work in leadership
inside of a team period
and now all of a sudden everything looks
connected and now all of a sudden when
you start
when you when you learn a move in jiu
jitsu
when you're learning to move into jiu
jitsu and you don't know anything
that move is a is a solitary thing by
itself it's
unsupported in any way you really can't
even barely even utilize that move
because it's just by itself you know you
don't even know what position to get
into you don't know how to get into that
position you don't know how to set it up
you don't have it you don't know
anything
you know that move but it's it's so easy
to forget because it's not connected to
anything else
the better you get the more knowledge
you have all of a sudden you start
putting these things together and now
they become a system
now they're all interrelated and now
when you see something here something
it fits in you see how it fits into
this overall broad view of things which
is why you know we constantly are
quoting
if you see the way if you see the way
broadly you'll see it in all things
and that's what this is but it takes a
certain level
of understanding before you can see the
way broadly
and you know i talk to young guys that
are going in the seal teams
and and they just have no
this stuff isn't even on the it's not
even on the radar
in any way shape or form right and part
of it is because
they don't see the seal teams they see
the seal teams as like oh i'm gonna go
make it through buds and i'm gonna go
and you know i'm gonna go run and we're
gonna shoot machine guns they don't
understand
what this profession is and it's better
now than it was i mean the guys when
when i came in i didn't freaking
understand any of this stuff in any way
shape or form i barely even understood
what it meant to
okay you're going to be part of this
squad
and this squad has responsibilities to
an overall
i barely grasp any of that
but as you start to assemble this
information and so that's what's hard
so going back to working with the client
like until you can start bringing things
together
for them until they start connecting
these things in their own head that's
another thing
is i can sit there and with a ball-peen
hammer hit you with one spot and go
cover and move cover and move cover and
move until
you see that cover and move is connected
to these other things
it's it's very very difficult to force
the knowledge onto that onto another
human yeah
and i made the comment earlier about i
wish i knew these things
there's a whole bunch of reasons why you
simply can't at the beginning just like
you described like i said
second lieutenant dave burke almost
can't know this
no matter how crystal clear these
lessons are from world war ii
and forever back
and the other side of that though is
that
even even when you can it's it still
never ends finding more to know dude i
i taught it top gun the the
the the argument the apex of aviation
and the pinnacle and all these things
that we use to describe top gun this
phd level graduate level system
of combat aviation top gun you know what
i was teaching there
cover and move cover and move and do you
know why i was teaching cover and move
because the mistakes that top gun made
the students made to go through top gun
were mistakes they weren't doing cover
and move
even at that level the reason i was
talking about
simple plans at top gun we didn't use
the same words
but i was teaching that same thing is
because the plans weren't simple and
nobody really understood them and they
got admissions and come back and hey
why'd they screw that up well these guys
didn't listen to me
well that could be it but actually it's
probably not
what probably is that you didn't explain
it very well the reason i was teaching
these same simple fundamental things at
top gun is that those are the mistakes
that are being made repeatedly by some
of the best most experienced pilots in
the world
and as i hear myself say i wish
i knew this stuff and almost now
laughing at the phrase know this stuff
it's crazy how even now that i know
it's so much more than i ever knew what
i really know is how little i still
really know and how much more there is
out there and that's why every time you
break out another book i'm like dude
that book was awesome
even though it's saying the exact same
things
they're all saying um but that's
actually
that's actually really good because we
get to
do this again yeah we get to do it over
and over again
yeah and get to see it from a different
angle and get to understand it a little
bit
deeper like when this example
comes in the pyramid goes up just a
little bit more
and it ties together another little part
of your brain
and i often wonder
you know there's some lessons that you
cannot teach
to someone like they have to have to
experience it
right and there's unfortunately a lot of
lessons like that let's face it
let's face it that is the vast majority
of lessons because everyone otherwise
everyone
would you know get issued a certain book
at age 12 and here's what you need to
know and they'd be like oh cool
got it okay uh save my money okay eat
healthy okay you know
there's all these fundamental things
that a human being could do
that if you did all these fundamental
things and
and by the way these are not hidden
knowledge these are
common knowledge these are these are
just common knowledge things that
everyone kind of knows
and yet we think it's going to be
different for us
we think we can i don't need i'm going
to do it a little bit differently
and it's no that's not going to work no
it's not going to work
so taking these
things and that's what that's another
good thing is you have to experience
them but
some in some way you have to experience
in that and that's one good thing that
happens at echelon front
is you are in an environment where
you get to use this stuff real world and
that's been interesting
you know sort of after the first six
weeks of the covid lockdown
not even six weeks the feedback we
started getting was
from from many of the companies we work
with was
this stuff really works and the reason
that they were saying is because they'd
never really been tested in it before
yeah you know they're doing great they
want to do even better and now they go
and do better
and they go wow this stuff really works
doesn't it
so hard to learn and the thing that
makes it hardest to learn
is if you fall into the trap of
i know it i wish there was another i'm
familiar with it right there's got to be
a lesser form of i know because i know
it's a
there's that's a hundred percent i know
is 100
there should be a lesser form of no
maybe i'm familiar with
i i i understand at a
decent level some of the concepts that
we talk about
this is not new to me yeah this is not
new to me that sounds a little bit
is that a little bit kind of yeah
is it a little bit arrogant though yeah
oh okay that's why
that's kind of part of the gig it's not
no i'm looking for a word that actually
says
i'm very familiar with this but i know
that i have a lot to learn we should oh
you want the opposite yes
okay okay yeah the word for how i feel
the word for how we should all feel yes
i am striving to be better i'm familiar
i know that these things exist and i
know that i don't
yeah like them like basically saying
you're a white belt at this
yeah maybe it's like saying i'm a purple
belt at this yeah
which is that i'm just on the path yeah
yeah
yeah hoiler back in the day long time
ago i did a website for him and he was
at my house and it was me
and kit pellegro and hoyler what's up
kid
what's up hey there yeah and so where
me and kid belligero were texting after
we had egg zone he's like
so we're looking at it and he's like hey
we're trying to integrate
his you know we're doing some technical
stuff right so i'm doing this i was like
okay this is what you got to do you got
to do this i think and he's like
maybe if we did this so we tried it his
way boom and it worked so it like you
know it rendered on the screen
and hoyler's like it's his website but
he doesn't know this part he's like
oh i'm a white belt at this stuff and it
gave me that feeling
that that you just mentioned right now
like it reminded me of that time kind of
like
he knows what's going on but he has no
idea how deep it goes you know
in the back end like that yeah well
there's that there's definitely that
time period when you start jiu jitsu
and you the first couple days it takes a
little while to go wow
i really don't know a lot because in the
beginning you think it's finite
yeah that's the big difference in the
beginning you think it's
13 moves and then you go oh wait it's
actually
probably 35 moves when i started jiu
jitsu i thought it was nine moves i
thought that was the whole thing
give me my black belt up in here i know
the americana
i know the guillotine i know the rear
naked choke i'm good
wha what what give me my black belt
and then you get really good at it and
the better you get the more you realize
you know i don't know some i don't know
a lot of stuff there's a lot of stuff
out there we did not know
and that's the way this is that's the
way this
is then you get the and like i said the
biggest thing you gotta watch out for is
that trap
and we gotta avoid the trap and speaking
of avoiding the trap
and speaking of staying on the path echo
charles we want to avoid the trap
of complacency complacency we want to
improve we want to get better we want to
be better
recommendations so complacency and well
how do i
you know where why does complacency come
in
as far as working out goes because you
think you're good
you think you're good to go or maybe you
don't need it as much or whatever
because here's a big one it's going to
sound kind of offbeat
maybe maybe not i don't know but let's
say you get
married kids that's the easy one
my favorite thing is when people tell me
oh man i was really into jiu jitsu but
i got two kids yeah and i was just
looking i got four kids
what you yeah as if
well i'm old i've had people going yeah
i'm just all old now
like how old are you they're like i'm 42
i'm like bruh
but there's two there's two
uh kind of kind of reasons or excuses or
whatever there when they're like i got
kids that's either saying i don't
have time well okay so back to the
working out thing
when you when you after you get married
there's two reasons kind of like oh well
my focus is on something else now
you know meaning like i don't really
have time to do these extra
curricular things and then the other one
is um i don't need to anymore because a
lot of people that's kind of whether
they
have it consciously or not it's like
well i don't need to necessarily be in
great shape because i already have a
girl kind of thing because
part of their reason is to attract a
girl it's insane
and it goes both ways a two-way street
obviously so
that can be one of the reasons for
complacency like i don't need to stay in
shape that much
most definitely yeah i don't need to
lift heavy anymore not to say you should
be lifting heavy not to say
not to say you shouldn't be but i'm just
saying that that's a potential excuse
i'm saying anyway lifting heavy or not
doing jiu jitsu or not
because some of us are not doing jiu
jitsu not recommended but those are the
facts some of them meaning it's not
recommended to not do jiu jitsu correct
that's a problem
but those those are the facts some of
the time you see insane
unless do you find it weird that i sit
here and say that
these kind of connections that opened
the door
to begin to understand some of this
stuff came from this weird thing where
you roll around on the floor with
another person and try and choke them
yeah it's kind of weird right yeah you
know
um from maybe yeah from the outside i
can see that
but the inside you're like bro this is
this thing is just completely explaining
jiu-jitsu
you know what's a weird parallel as well
as like lifting weights and just your
human body
the human body how it works is like the
same thing it's like a team of systems
that's true doing one thing for the
other you know and they have to cover
and move for each other they gotta adapt
it's like all this stuff anyway speaking
of human body
you need supplements if you're going
hard in the paint on the path
you used to say supplementation it was
kind of one of your
go-to words and now you've gone back you
know now you're just saying like
supplements
yeah yeah does that sound more like
markety
i don't know i just was really used to
you saying supplementation which was not
a normal thing to say
right it seems like maybe you're just
sort of falling in with the norm maybe
you got peer pressured
maybe all right well let's go back to
supplementation because
now they say you just said it i feel
good now the way
like you just feel like you're back
exactly
well you're saying it kind of brought to
light like yeah i kind of like how
supplementation
sounds it's insane when you're on the
path in the game going hard
which we are you know we are unless
we're not i don't know did you live
today
i did not lift weights today i'm gonna
live afterwards not yet yeah
hardcore oh yeah for sure until failure
anyway your joints sometimes take a
beating
right supplementation will help that as
dave burke says
no factor we got supplementation for
that
joint warfare super krill oil which i
took both of today i'm on the routine
of course i got some help from you
obviously but you know some people
out on the interwebs out in the field
you know they're demonstrating that they
can stick to that routine leaving it
out on the uh did you make adjustments
yes sir you got them in your bathroom
now
no where on the counter in the kitchen
where i always come down i always come
down
see insane but you said the bathroom was
just a no-go non-starter well you don't
like to be eating stuff in your bathroom
even it's just a little
capsule given my current routine yeah
i said i said go pills to
belittle brian littlefield that was the
original thing
and i don't like to take you so there's
i didn't know this
there's a difference between a capsule
which has the little coating it's got
stuff inside it
and a pill is like a hard thing right
yeah
and they're a little bit harder to
swallow or whatever
i found the capsules are harder oh
really i found yeah well
that's too bad you're not in charge of a
supplement company
because the original go pills that he
made were i said hey make these things i
want to you know have the stuff in
dismal glow but make it
make it um make it you know smaller so i
the whole story was hey man
you know this dave you don't want to you
don't have to drink
a drink before you go and present to a
group for two a half hours
because you don't have to say hey can i
hold on this thing a little bio break
here
no in fact when people when people tell
me
hey you know while you're speaking we're
gonna put waters up here and i say if i
drink
if i have to drink during the next one
hour if i go
hold on a second while i'm presenting i
need to take a drink right now
because my voice is dry if i have to do
that we got a problem i failed
you're not you don't want to you're not
sitting there so you can see me drink
we're not drinking now if i'm up during
the muster i'm on
stage for six hours yeah we're up there
drinking and chilling and whatever
plus you guys are taking turns yeah yeah
but
the so the go pills i said hey man i
can't be drinking
a drink filling my bladder up while i'm
you know before because i don't want to
have to stop yes can you make something
compact compressed
there you go that's the discipline go in
a pill format
get that get that mind cranking
so just to be clear the discipline go is
a pill or a capsule
it is a capsule okay yes so the original
one that
belittle made was a pill because that's
what i had requested
i told them the wrong thing i didn't
understand the difference got to know
the lingo i guess
okay so pill compressed yes
capsule is a capsule that you can
unscrew and take the
powder out gel cap
and d vitamins those are the gel caps
yes they are
it's different so the three uh delivery
methodologies
you just to be clear yeah okay there you
go
so nonetheless these things will help
you
on the path big time also again we
mentioned the d3 boom that's
every that's a daily those are small too
so that's like kind of like no excuse
you know some people are like swallowing
swallowing pills some people like that
for sure this one no factor it's a gel
cap which is already i usually take i
used to take pills one at a time
yeah one like so i would take whatever
seven or eight pills right so
i would take one one why just just i
just didn't like it yeah kind of like
what you're saying
i was one of those people and then i
realized it was inefficient
and i had to overcome this you know
scenario i'll tell you the technique to
swallow pills you swallow 10 pills at
once if you want well i've never tried
it but i'm saying given the theory
theoretically because i
what do i take and this is all at once
uh two
diva uh 2d vitamins oh you take two of
those yeah i take
okay go ahead uh three krill oil
three joint warfare and every once in a
while don't throw into cold war
so what is that two six i don't know i
didn't do the math nonetheless it's a
lot let's say it's six yeah i take all
those at once
yeah all you gotta do is when you drink
your water with it wait you drink water
with it
yeah that you know some guys are
advanced they just boom yeah that's one
speed it's a hardcore dude right there
yeah
you know um but we're not all there so
we're gonna drink our water with it but
bro all you do some people they lean
their head back
oh here's the thing when you lean your
head back like that
the narrative the throat chamber no well
i don't know maybe maybe not but that's
not what i found
uh as far as feet feelings go the uh
those capsules that you talk about they
float in the water
you want it to sink really the pills
sink
especially if they're coated with
something god anyway
so if you go straight up straight back
boom the gel caps float sometimes they
don't go
go down interesting this is what you do
you turn your head to the side
okay see what i'm saying no because look
it still floats but since it's to the
side it's on the side of your throat
not on the top of it so it goes down
easier five pills learning something new
every day
there i was thinking i knew how to take
capsules
you know now i learned the truth i guess
technically i shouldn't even say that's
the best way i'm
so currently that is the leading way my
little daughter was getting sick
and i said hey you need to take some
cold war
and so then she's she does not like to
take pills or capsules
and i said no problem i broke it open
mix it up in water
it was water you cannot do this because
it is
because there's garlic in there like a
lot of garlic which
which is an awesome ingredient to have
but
man i mixed it up and it was nasty yeah
try it with one just to
just kind of just to kind of see
that would be a that would be a dis that
would be an exercise in discipline just
mix up
cold war pills and just drink them like
shots yeah
ah man i think maybe sprinkle them on
some eggs or some or maybe some bacon or
something that might be
actually interesting interesting concept
but uh that's the thing though i'm sure
cold war is not just
garlic powder yeah no no sure there's
some like actual that's
when you mix it with water and smell it
all right well nonetheless however you
choose to take these things they will
help you
100 percent in the game on the path
understand don't forget about milk
protein forming of dessert protein
additional protein
it's not like you're not eating protein
but if you weren't it would be
boom now you are yeah there you go
what else chocolate white tea yes we're
dead
it's not like we're not dead lifting
unless we're not i should be dead left
we should be i think so that's my
opinion too um well what does dr white
have to do with that because it allows
you
to deadlift eight thousand pounds eight
yeah yeah yeah
well that's the guarantee could be right
right it could be money if you go hard i
guess
and you get all the stuff at the vitamin
shop the vitamin shop
in your local ao area of operations yes
sir
also at origin mean dot com if you want
to go to the vitamin shop you want the
delivery
system to your door
and you go yeah origin main.com also at
origin main.com is jiu jitsu stuff
geez rash guards um you know
there's t-shirts and you know other
clothes or whatever but
more importantly actually not
importantly but additionally
significantly additionally
jeans and boots there's something else
coming
that you probably don't even know about
because you're not
really like you know building good
relationships with the inner circle
apparently so you know the the material
that the gee pants are made of yes it's
called atomic twill
so and it's it's durable enough to be
g-pants obviously
and uh i was like pete
what do you think i could use just a
pair of pants
so he he made them and they are freaking
legit
yeah like a work pencil yeah like work
pants but they're yeah they're basically
just pants but they're not jeans
yeah they'll be coming they'll be
working
yeah yes all made in america by the way
which is a big deal
fabric cotton grown in america all the
way to the to the
to the deal what about what about like
the things that you put together to make
them
stay up you know what i mean there's a
certain thing there what's that called i
don't know what you're talking about
what's it called that that keeps the two
pieces of cotton fabric together
what's it called i don't know not the
zipper above the zipper is the
button that's right yeah yeah the
buttons yes even the buttons are made in
america
works of art really function and fashion
as it were nonetheless
your main dot com is where you get all
this good stuff also speak
speaking of getting good stuff wait dave
how do you like the
jocko palmer gonna go go can i liked it
is it is it the top of your list are you
because you're on a
what back savage what where are we no
hit on
on dak savage but i was doing some
tropic thunder
but now that now that palmer's in a can
that's number one right it just just
went to the top well dude palmer powder
is all i had
yeah and uh the thing about go
is like i get them because i'm going
somewhere
i'm on the go so i don't have time to
mix up the powder all the time
the powder was like almost a treat
almost like milk yeah
i'm like i got time here i'm going to
get crushed ice i'm going to get the
powder i'm going to mix it up i got some
thyme
and i'm going to just now done
all day yeah you know yeah i agree with
the jocko palmer scenario
like you it's it was kind of
surprisingly good you know when you
think oh yeah oh ice cream
lemon cool nice nothing new hey this is
nothing new to me
boom take a hit the sum is greater than
the sun
what is that there's the parts you you
see what i'm saying but anyway it was
that sort of situation
it's good no good anyway speaking of
good jocko has a store it's called
diagonal store this is where you can get
your t-shirts hoodies hats
other cool stuff on there that represent
on the path discipline equals freedom
good take the high ground or the high
ground will take you
all this stuff you can find
jackostory.com really uh
you know we think that it's cool stuff
but you know go on there
check it out if you like something get
something
in all these ways by the way if you just
like the podcast and you want to support
it these are good ways
to support the podcast because other
than that well i mean
the podcast we don't have it behind the
firewall
okay you are yeah paywall right firewall
that's what everybody wants me to do
yeah put it behind the paywall yeah
they they want that because all the
podcasts are now the new
media stuff yeah
so well varying levels of advantage we
don't want to do that
we just want to do what we're doing yeah
and in order to do what we're doing
a little support is nice on that one hey
if you and speaking of this podcast
subscribe to it check it out
echo charles thinks that's important for
me to say right now
i don't think it's unimportant how about
that we also have another podcast that's
out right now it's called
the unraveling the jocko unraveling
podcast daryl cooper and me talking
about
things in the world and how things in
the world
when you unravel them you find out where
they came from why they're happening and
it gives you a better understanding of
the things that are happening
right now it used to be called the
thread we had to change the name
there's also grounded podcasts which we
haven't recorded in a while but we're
gonna write on the
warrior kid podcast as well don't forget
about the warrior kid soap made by aiden
who's up there in a farm taking goat
milk
at a young age where they're running a
business
so that the entire world
can stay clean we got a youtube channel
where echo charles is supposed to make
videos
and he does sometimes we'll say sure i'm
not gonna argue with that one
some of them have explosions music
sometimes yeah some have music and other
enhancements
yeah skeletons sure fire
sure tanks aircraft sometimes yeah
unless some don't yeah and everyone that
thinks that echo charles should put one
easter egg easter egg one pleasant
surprise
into these three hour podcasts
like when dave burke says a mortar
exploded
there should be a mortar exploding in
this room oh
just momentarily and then the
conversation can use a lot of people
think that's what should happen
so we all have a little bit of fun while
we're watching
a three hour yeah
okay we'll uh keep exploring that as an
option for sure
so what else oh yeah psychological
warfare don't forget about that one
hey when you don't feel like lifting
bruh i'll admit yesterday straight up
didn't feel like
i feel like lifting today but i did yeah
but you already have psychology report
for planing your head on repeat
you know one of those things yes
unfortunately
if you want it in your head maybe not on
a repeat maybe repeat for a little bit
yeah that's how you get it go to like
you know wherever you can buy mp3s
amazon
you know google play all these places
get psychological warfare
by jocko willing what it is is jocko
talking in your ear
telling you why you shouldn't skip the
workout why you shouldn't
eat the doughnut pound that donut or the
whole box or whatever
nutter butter cookies you know you get
dipper um nonetheless so you know
gently pragmatically logically
bring you past those moments of weakness
and boom you get you get stuff
done it's really good 100 uh effective
too by the way
flip side canvas if you want some kind
of message to hang on your wall
my brother dakota meyer is making it for
you
all kinds of messages important messages
check that out flipsidecampus.com
got some books one of them was written
by this guy right over here dave burke
the code the code the evaluation the
protocols what do you got what do you
got dave
they're still getting a ton of messages
from troopers who are still
on the path and in the game and it's so
legit to hear
something as small as this little what
it's a field
guide yeah field guide we weren't really
sure what to call it no
but it's it's been you it's useful yeah
uh which has been awesome so keep those
messages coming man i love hearing from
you yeah this is like one of those
things where you know i called it like a
reminder
almost but it it's kind of like okay
cool everybody doesn't make you know
that much of an impact maybe on your
mind but think about it
every day at let's say at the end of the
day right
most of us don't think every single day
most of us don't think how did i do
today
how did i do today in all these like
critical areas as far as like making an
improvement in what you're even doing
imagine if you
were part of anything and you never
assessed
that thing yeah doesn't even compute
imagine if you wanted to make something
better
you would assess that thing and see
where you can improve it now imagine
that the most important thing we have
is our lives and people go through their
whole lives without assessing
where they are who they are what they're
doing
where they're going most important thing
you need to know on the battlefield is
where you are
yeah then you can move forward yeah
that's that's the that's the protocols
in this book
it's funny like you know when like
you're a kid and you're trying to like i
don't know
make the football team right and you
have like tryouts which
you know a day or a week or whatever
sometimes a week or whatever
and after every little session you like
come home and you're like how did i do
how did i do what did i do that's just
for some intramural football game
we're talking about life see i'm saying
yeah you would think it'd be more
obvious you would
think yeah that that that that book
would just be hey this is
hey what are you guys doing writing this
there's you know there's this already
exists
yeah what are you doing writing this it
doesn't exist
now it does the code the evaluation the
protocols
dave burke leadership strategy and
tactics what percentage
of questions that you get in your
constant
leadership as a leadership instructor as
a leadership
coach as an executive coach what
percentage
of questions are answered that you have
to answer
that you could either answer on the fly
and say hey here's a good way to look at
it or you could if you had
an extra 14 seconds say hold on a second
go to page 237 in leadership strategy
attack us what's the percentage
it's a big number
i don't want to do the math it's a big
number i don't want to say it's all
there because that would be
that'd be a lot to say it's all there
but it's there and if it's not exactly
there there's a version of it that's
there that will fit wherever you are
the other side is just just read that
book just read it
and it's there yeah
i i think what's good about that book is
the stuff that we're talking about today
where you have to pull these
other things and you kind of want to
start fitting them together
i think this that book is a good step of
taking these various principles and
starting to see how they
play into the world which i think is a
good thing
yes uh kids
you you might have kids you might know
kids you might as well get them on the
path
weigh the warrior kid one two and three
those are available those are helpful
i'm telling you right now if you could
get a kid
these books you are going to change the
trajectory of their lives and i know
that's an
arrogant and a and a bold statement to
make
but i hear it all the time from parents
from teachers and from kids themselves
it's it's just just please just get it
for the kids
get it for the kids um and then if you
got a smaller kid
think about when it's like being a small
kid the world
you have to contend with the world it's
a scary place we have fears to overcome
mikey and the dragons teach kids
how to overcome fear discipline goes
freedom field manual
how to get after it for adults
and extreme ownership and the dichotomy
of leadership the fundamental principles
of combat leadership that we talk about
all the time that i wrote with my
brother leif babin
we have echelon front leadership
consultancy what do we do there dave
we teach leadership now we help make the
connection between all this stuff and
the world that these people are living
in and it's
the coolest thing in the world because i
get to
think about this stuff we get to think
about this stuff
all the time yeah which is just
completely awesome real world
application yes on a daily basis into a
multitude of scenarios
and the outcomes are always the same
it's like
yes we actually know what to do there
and we can help you go to go to
echelonfront.com for that
and look you don't have to necessarily
have us to come to you
or you don't necessarily have to come to
us we had to cancel one of our musters
that bummed a lot of people out me you
all of us we got bummed out
but this is this is 2020.
we are online ef online
all the stuff that we're talking about
when you need direct
contact to help get through things to
improve your leadership
capability to improve your team's
leadership capability to get you all
aligned
go to efonline.com you might be thinking
that oh that sounds like something where
i'll go on there and
and watch a video about something and
you you will go you can go and watch
videos
but you can also come and ask dave burke
a question you can come and ask
me a question you can argue with me you
can say actually jocko cover move didn't
work for me in this situation
i will gladly discuss this with you
that is what we are doing with ef online
so
it's awesome what'd i miss dave
have you talked about because we have a
whole new platform right now for ef
online
good point and yes
the the the feedback we're getting on
that is how how easy it is
for people out there to connect with us
directly in real time
not to talk theory not to talk principle
but to talk i'm having this actual
problem or can you help me
yes i can and then we're getting
we're getting feedback we're getting
sitrep sit reps hey the thing you told
me
yesterday i just did it it worked thanks
and if you haven't you need to tell
people about this because the ef online
access
is so legit it's it's growing quickly
but it's growing because
one of the other cool things about it is
that we'll get a ques we're talking
we'll get a question like a little chat
box
dave cut a question but i'll be
answering another question
before i get to that next question five
other people
other troopers have said hey had the
same problem
at my job this is what i did and by the
time i go to answer it
five other troopers have already engaged
and helped them and given them some
so the interaction between the other
troopers is just as good as the
interaction with us yeah and all that
stuff is taking place on we have a forum
in there too so all that stuff
you can go in there and say hey my boss
just told me to do this this is what i
think and
and you know one of us ef instructors
or one of the other troopers you know oh
you know what i'm in hr
i'm the hr chief at my company here's
what you should think about so it's
it's just an awesome format it's an
awesome thing and even though we had to
cancel one muster uh we do we are going
to do the phoenix muster
september 16th and 17th dallas december
3rd and 4th
go to extreme ownership.com for details
look it's probably gonna be social
distancing we're not gonna have a bunch
of seats
we're gonna have to give we have to put
away a bunch of seats so it's gonna sell
out quicker than normal
so if you wanna come check it out asap
we got ef overwatch
and we are placing some awesome people
from the military
into executive leadership positions and
leadership positions
throughout the country in awesome
businesses people that
companies that want to have folks that
understand the principles that we talk
about here
go to efoverwatch.com whether you need
leaders
or whether you are a leader leaving the
military let us know and we will connect
you
and then america's mightywarriors.org
mark lee's mom mama lee
who has made it her mission to help
families service members
gold star families all over the world if
you want to get involved with her
she is getting after it and she has been
for 14 years and if you want to help out
or get involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org
and if you want some more of my
hyped up hypotheses or you want to hear
more of echo's semi serious
speculations or maybe you just
want to hear one more of dave's
stringent
stories then you can find us on the
interwebs
on twitter on instagram and on facebook
dave is at david
r burke echo is that aqua charles and i
am at
jocko willink and thank you to all the
men and women in uniform
throughout history who learned these
lessons
in blood and passed them on to our
modern warriors who put them
to use put these lessons to use to keep
peace in the world
and to police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and emts and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol
and secret service thanks to all of you
for making sure we have peace here at
home
and to everyone else out there
remember these lessons and first and
foremost remember how this book
started that the paramount combat
lesson learned from every operation is
the
vital importance of leadership
aggressive and determined leadership is
the
priceless factor which inspires
command and upon which
all success in battle depends
leadership is responsible for success or
failure
so don't fall into the trap
we are not good enough go out there
and be better
and until next time this is dave and
echo
and jocko out